et bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la
chaîne de Gauthier Geo spoil pour ce
troisième épisode des Breizh de spolium
de roll of Science moi c'est the Wilou
je vais être le MJ pour cette soirée
scénariste également et je vais tout de
suite présenter mes invités parce que
j'ai rien de spécial à dire cette
fois-ci donc
on est sur la chaîne de Gautier juste
ici bonjour bienvenue comment ça va ça
va très bien ça va très bien est-ce que
petit rituel comme toutes les émissions
est-ce que tu peux te présenter oui
Gauthier
motivation de foule non mais je sais
plus quoi dire
voilà on parle ma chaîne juin voilà
c'était ça que je cherchais on parle de
géologie mais pas que
voilà ce que j'ai besoin de dire plus
que ça la preuve on fait un JdR
aucune cohérence éditoriale
super bien en tout cas
allez voir c'est bien en vrai
dans la CCI on a besoin de gens comme ça
qui font du porte-à-porte comme ça et
qui vendent la bonne nouvelle de voilà
du développement économique toujours
tes réseaux tu as des commandes pour SMS
Fredo tout dans le chat twitch et ça ça
vous le donnera des liens voilà donc
n'hésitez pas ou alors demander au modo
ensuite à la gauche Valentine bonjour
comment vas-tu
bien ça va tranquille super
est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour les
gens qui ne te connaîtriez pas
je vais prendre celle-là bonjour je
m'appelle Valentine de sciences de
comptoir et je parle beaucoup trop fort
et aussi donc je parle de caillou sur ma
chaîne youtube et aussi Twitter et
Instagram et je fais cette blague la
dernière fois je crois et voilà et c'est
tout et on est vraiment aussi bon à cet
exercice quoi
bonjour
pour la prochaine fois chacun peut
présenter un autre c'était drôle
pareil donc tu as des commandes dans le
chat point d'exclamation Valentine pour
l'exclamation églantine et pour
l’exclamation science de comptoir
voilà pour les voir tes réseaux
également si vous voulez voir ton
travail merci à ma droite mais un peu
plus loin que que Fredo Gauthier tout ça
là on a Clotilde oui bonsoir tout le
monde donc oui Clotilde de la chaîne
passe et sauvage qui est une chaîne qui
a bientôt 7 ans et qui vulgarise
l'archéologie l'entrepologie l'histoire
et sur ma chaîne vous pouvez voir du
format classique du fascam et sinon je
vous emmène sur le terrain voir des
fouilles archéologiques en direct ça
s'appelle mission archéo pardon c'est la
peur la poussière voilà génial c'est une
vidéo il y a pas longtemps moi aussi je
peux péter
deux semaines je suis sur les réseaux
Tik Tok Instagram twitch aussi donc je
suis partout
[Rires]
en fait je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
quelque chose et ça il y a un robot qui
te répond et du coup nous ça répond à
lire des réseaux sociaux en fait elle
est tellement pro qu'elle fait semblant
de pas savoir comme ça ça permet de ça
pour vous expliquer un petit peu du coup
toi tu as
prises sauvage et pour l'exclamation
rien
il faut le faire comme ça
ça continue
dans notre personnage
Arnaud de ce qu'il économics qui
interprète Alain Chicheportiche qui a
apparemment
j'en ai oublié mes prénoms euh si vous
voulez toutes les émotions
donc
dans dans la vie ailleurs que en JDR
donc j'ai la chaîne stupide économique
c'est du journaliste mais
le traitement en fait de thème de
société donc là par exemple en ce moment
je suis en train de travailler sur une
crise du logement en cours à venir tout
ça donc c'est un gros sujet qui va
bientôt sortir et mes points
d'exclamation
donc mes points d'exclamation donc les
commandes c'est Arnaud ou alors
Pierre-Alain Chicheportiche comme ça
s'écrit
le dernier stupid economique avec ça
vous aurez toutes les infos ce sera plus
simple Arnaud
voilà sinon si vous arrivez pas à écrire
les commandes à vous demander dans le
chat il y a des gens qui veillent au
grain et qui vont faire en sorte de les
écrire à votre place
on remercie le CNC de nous aider à
financer ce joli projet et le quai des
savoirs qui nous prête le studio dans le
cadre de leur expo feu et mégafeux à
Toulouse si vous êtes à Toulouse allez
ok c'est cool
voilà
vous dernière vous êtes à l'intérieur
votre écran vous pouvez
influer sur l'histoire donc surveiller
bien le chat il va y avoir des sondages
qui vont apparaître qui vont vous
permettre de choisir des choses qui vont
se passer ou non pour nos aventuriers un
petit peu après le sondage d'autant que
moi je les intègre dans l'histoire il y
aura également des quiz si vous répondez
en majorité juste vous poserez le choix
de donner un bonus ou un malus au
prochain jeu de dés des aventuriers
voilà c'est votre manière à vous de
d'influer sur l'histoire en plus de ça à
la fin on va se retrouver pour une
trentaine de minutes ou de discussions
juste pure scientifique ou juste des
points qu'on a envie de reparler et là
vous pourrez nous poser n'importe quelle
question dans le chat actuellement on
peut pas vous lire mais à la fin on
pourra vous dire donc si jamais vous
avez des questions gardez les vous en
tête et venez nous les poser à la fin
voilà voilà
je pense qu'on peut lancer du coup
[Musique]
Gaston Fournier un scientifique du
complexe scientifique adixia c'est
comment renvoyer notre groupe dans le
passé et pour ça il a besoin de
travailler une semaine sur son prototype
une semaine que le général Beaulieu
compte bien mettre à profit en effet il
souhaite empêcher la catastrophe
d'arriver et pour ce faire il faut
découvrir la cause de l'apparition des
particules noires avant de renvoyer nos
héros chez eux
mais il souhaite d'abord s'assurer qu'il
peut leur faire confiance et pour ce
faire il leur a demandé de l'aider à
mettre la main sur la production de
spolium de la région
après une journée d'enquête au sein
d'horizon ils ont découvert que la
majorité des notes sur la production de
spolium ont été détruites et que le
secret de fabrique est gardé
précieusement dans un village voisin
iridis
au cours de leur enquête Eglantine a pu
rencontrer sa descendance qui les a mis
en relation avec un convoyeur qui fait
des trajets entre iridis et horizon du
nom de Romain Delim ce dernier les a
conduits vers le village à l'aide de son
véhicule de fortune
ils ont été déposés devant l'entrée du
village un grand panneau de bois sur
lequel est gravé bienvenue à iridis
surplombe une grande allée pavée qui
mène droit vers un gigantesque feu de
joie qui siège au centre de ce qu'il
semble être une grande pièce remplie
d'un grand marché une grande place
pardon remplie d'un grand marché
le spectacle est fait Éric car vous
marquez que les rues ne sont pas
éclairées par des lampadaires de spolium
comme à horizon mais par des sortes de
canaux incrustés dans le sol de couleur
différente ce qui vous donne
l'impression d'être trop beau milieu
d'un arc-en-ciel
[Musique]
ça me donne l'impression d'être au
milieu d'un
train de me dire la même chose
de nuit
est-ce que on peut peut-être s'approcher
des échappes si c'est un marché
pour aller voir un peu ce qu'il en
retourne
et se font dans la masse par exemple
à quoi ressemble les locaux justement ce
qu'on voit des gens qui parlent
excusez-moi j'ai oublié d'ouvrir le chat
pour qu'il me donne
un nouveau village il y a beaucoup de
gens c'est très peuplé c'est un village
vous vous ne le connaissez pas de votre
époque il n'existait pas ce village
iridis
toi peut-être que tu sais ce que ça veut
dire de ton origine grec
moi ça me fait penser aux yeux ou une
pierre
vous avancez sur cette grande allée et
vous arrivez sur cette place du village
qui est bondée de gens il y a énormément
de détails de marchands il y a de tout
avant que vous pouvez voir il y a
n'importe quoi de la nourriture des
vraiment vous pouvez chercher tout ce
que vous voulez sur cette place vous
allez le trouver et vous vous sentez
étrangement bien en entrant là vous
voyez le grand feu de joie qui brûle du
spodium bleu
extrêmement fort et qui éclaire toute
cette place
vous pouvez aller parler à n'importe qui
bon déjà nous on cherche la source
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en reste ensemble
on se sépare déjà je vous quitte et je
vais acheter un blanc de poulet non un
blanc de dinde d'accord pour ma
consommation personnelle crue et donc je
demande au comptoir bonjour je voudrais
un blanc de dinde cru bonjour et du coup
à combien je vous dois c'est 8 euros
s'il vous plaît très bien alors là je
sors de mon porte-monnaie une pièce que
je pose et je regarde la tête du
ministre s'il est content ou pas il
regarde il dit ah c'est de l'ancienne
monnaie oui
ça voudra 16 du coup un ancienne monnaie
très bien donc là je lui tends l'argent
pour
moi
donc non
si vous voulez me rejoindre
devant lui
je calcule extrêmement vite donc ce que
tu as remarqué oui c'est que déjà les
prix sont affichés en trois devises
différentes les iris les dollars
d'horizon
je crois apparemment c'est une nouvelle
forme de dollars et des Lys
il y a pas d'anciennes monnaie c'est
juste c'est possiblement ils prennent
aussi d'accord
je demande au boucher ah dis donc vous
avez du monde qui vient de loin
oui c'est la place tournante du commerce
de la région on a
tous les villages aux alentours et on
ramène les meilleurs mets
vraiment
succulent et là en fait j'attends juste
que les gens viennent pour m'aider parce
que je sais pas quoi demander
du coup vous moi je m'approche du
boucher normal du coup vous remarquez
que donc il porte un masque et des gants
monsieur pourquoi pourquoi vous protéger
la bouche bah quoi mais ce qu'il y a une
maladie qui traîne c'est pour l'hygiène
hygiène de quoi par rapport la
nourriture que je vends à mes clients
de batterie de spolium pour pour nos
torches c'est à quel boutique
du coup je crois que là-bas ils vendent
des choses en rapport avec des torches
de spolium
où est-ce qu'il fabrique voilà c'est ça
est-ce qu'on peut prendre nos
[Musique]
j'aimerais me rendre à cette dont vous
vous baladez vous avez tous me faire un
G d'intelligence oh là là là
84 sur 40 pour trouver une échoppe non
j'ai l'impression d'y arriver
66 sur 65
alors les trois qui ont raté
vous allez devoir acheter quelque chose
dans ce marché il y a un peu de tout
donc je vais vous faire une petite liste
sachant que toi vu que tu as celui qui a
le plus raté
le chat a décidé que tu allais t'acheter
une torche de spolium de luxe
donc vous pouvez trouver dans ce marché
entre autres si vous avez d'autres idées
vous pouvez me dire dites-vous qu'il y a
de tout juste je vous donne des idées en
vrac il y a des légumes de la viande du
fromage et des outils de bricolage des
piles lance de spolium des torches de
spolium des bijoux des boissons ou des
vêtements par exemple
je vais je m'écarte un peu du groupe
et j'approche du commerçant qui va la
torche donc je vais dire elle est belle
votre torche mon beau monsieur donc là
il me dit merci
combien vous la vendez c'est 50 euros 50
tiroirs est-ce que tout hasard vous
seriez faire la conversion avec de
l'ancienne monnaie donc là je lui montre
c'est 100 d'anciennes monnaie
ah oui
et il y a des promotions de temps en
temps ou
pas sur mes articles de luxe vous doutez
bien que c'est des pièces uniques
faites-moi de l'ancienne monnaie c'est
ça court pas les rues non plus quoi ah
oui mais ici on a tellement de monnaies
qui tournent que
ok peut-être que si vous mangez un
collectionneur elle voudra plus cher de
loin je vois
je les vois qui ont l'air de galérer
alors je m'approche et mon coeur de
cette conversation qu'est-ce qui se
passe
j'ai vu cette belle torche je me disais
qu'elle peut elle rendrait bien quoi
pour vous éclairer vous avez tout à fait
raison
combien elle coûte alors ça coûte 100
balles
donc 75 ok bon tu négocies un peu avec
lui et il accepte de te le faire à 40
donc 80 d'anciennes monnaies et voilà ça
c'est je lui donne 80 d'anciennes
monnaies
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle fait de elle
fait quelque chose de particulier
avec ça
qu'est-ce que tu veux acheter est-ce que
tu as parlé d'un collectionneur de
pièces et tout est-ce que ça compte
comme acheter si j'ai changé mes pièces
non j'ai parlé que je lui ai dit si
jamais il trouve un collectionneur
d'anciennes monnaies peut-être qu'il lui
reprendra plus cher et on n'a pas sur le
marché
toi aussi faut que tu achètes un truc on
sait utile
il y a une batterie dans ma torche elle
est venue avec une batterie donc elle
est vide mais elle est belle
les piles ça coûte 5 euros la pile
ok il faut combien de piles dans une
torche une seule à la fois
on prend deux piles qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez là je me tourne vers mes
compagnons on va dire depuis le c'est
combien donc du coup 10 donc si on vous
en prend 5 on passe à 20 quoi
marchander
parce que si on passe à 6 on pourrait
rester à 20
dans l'absolu c'est c'est pas un
problème marchandé à -10%
ah non après c'est compliqué de faire
des cales mais je marchande pour voilà
-10 sur ton jeu de dés ah ouais d'accord
oui
ça marche
sur 75 ok
moi j'essaye de trouver la boutique qui
a le truc le plus moderne un peu bizarre
enfin un truc je sais pas moi
impressionnerait quelques des personnes
dans le dans le passé
tu est-ce que juste tu cherches des yeux
ou tu veux poser des questions je
cherche des yeux des yeux il y a rien
qui te
qui tu reprends alors c'est juste un
marché un peu classique dans une rue
juste il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses
en vente mais il y a rien qui est
est-ce qu'il y a des contrefaçons de
maillots de l'OM
par exemple
[Rires]
on va marquer d'ailleurs que les
marchands auxquels vous avez acheté la
torche et pile ont aussi des gants et un
masque non mais ça je me doutais bien
que là on est en train de se faire un
toxiquer
[Musique]
des gants et des masques par hasard non
c'est pas logique ça
il y a des enfants dans ce marché on
peut pas acheter des enfants
ils ont des ils ont des gants et des
masques aussi
et je lui demande pourquoi vous avez un
masque et un tuba
je suis un peu ivre
tu vas à cause de la dinde
pourquoi pour éviter de d'abîmer la
marchandise
mais pourquoi vous avez peur d'abîmer le
sport
que je prenne mes précautions
on n'a pas besoin de se protéger pour
toucher à la Spadium
à la reine d'Angleterre
et les règles sont les règles
c'est pour vous protéger je viens vers
elle j'étais derrière c'est pour vous
protéger vous protéger un marchandises
qui sont obligatoires
on risque quelque chose
vous vous achetez si vous touchez sans
gants donc d'accord est-ce
qu'il y a de d'une provenance voilà du
local parce que nous on aime uniquement
ce qui est local
il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont
apportées sur ce marché mais
le spodium il est fabriqué à l'usine qui
est juste à côté de la place là et quand
il vous montre vous voyez un grand
bâtiment
à l'entrée alors là moi je commence à
lui parler de toute mon historique de
présidente
thermique enfin voilà vraiment le par le
menu en lui disant que je comprends
complètement ces problématiques de
commerçant enfin je veux dire c'est
voilà le développement économique avant
tout et je lui demande si il serait
possible que nous organise une visite
d'usine ou qu'il nous donne le contact
alors s'il vous plaît pouvez-vous nous
nous mettre en relation avec la personne
qui parce que vous allez en tant que
président de CCI il dit alors moi je
peux pas m'occuper de ça pour
personnellement je récupère ce qu'il y
en sorte de l'usine par contre je sais
qu'ils engagent à tour de bras donc si
vous voulez aller finir un coup de main
vous pouvez aussi en profiter pour
visiter l'usine oui après je pensais pas
forcément
un poste d'intérimaire mais je peux
tenter je suis prêt à tenter juste une
visite candidate je fais un petit
entretien je fais un peu le tour
ou un peu j'essaie de trouver une porte
dérobée je vais faire rentrer les
collègues
alors je je m'adresse merci beaucoup
pardon merci merci bonne journée je
m'adresse au compatriote en disant
est-ce qu'on organ
ise et c'était pas du tout celui-là
donc oui par exemple Fred si vous
vouliez c'était plus simple
et nous peut-être on pourra organiser
une petite visite à impromptude sécurité
au travail droit du travail je sais pas
il y a vous savez les mormons dans les
usines là qui font oh est-ce que c'est
bien en règle et ça vous le fabriquez
comment exactement se fasse passer pour
un service d'inspection
on peut faire les deux bénévoles parce
que quatre inspecteurs du travail ça me
paraît beaucoup là vous y allez vous
voir jeune et
nous comme on est vieux qu'est-ce qu'on
peut leur vendre comme pour qu'on leur
soit utile
ça vous permet d'aller partout vous vous
posez les questions que vous voulez vous
allez dans le sens que vous voulez
on fait les vieux quoi
ça me semble être un plan tout à fait
honorable solide on se dirige vers
l'usine ok alors on se passe un peu
devant
on arrive devant le vigile ouais
on a entendu dire que vous recrutiez et
là je j'en profite pour cracher par
terre pour montrer que je suis un peu
ouvrière aussi
on prend n'importe qui
vous affaires vous voir que vous avez
rien dit légal rien de dangereux vous
rentrez vous travaillez le en soit le
temps que vous voulez et vous êtes payé
à l'heure
c'est payé combien c'est 10 euros de
l'heure par personne
une batterie comme on peut savoir ça
consiste en quoi un peu le travail ça
c'est pas moi qui gère avant c'était
Mélissa qui qui s'occupait vous fallait
aller la voir et elle vous disait où
aller mais là ça fait quelques jours que
les pas revenu on sait pas trop
qu'est-ce qui lui est arrivé mais du
coup vous pouvez vous pouvez sûrement
aller voir Henri au premier étage et
vous dira quoi faire ok bah écoutez
merci vous êtes bien marre
allons-y
merci mon bras Mélissa c'est bien
la meuf que le mec à la mallette nous en
place
alors nous on est un petit peu en
retrait du coup à ce moment-là et on
arrive
à la suite on n'a pas préparé notre
pitch donc là je pense qu'on va pas être
très bon là du coup vous deux juste
avant que les autres arrivent ils vous
dis ok bon maintenant ce cas vous passez
au vestiaire il vous montre c'est juste
à côté vous vous changez et après vous
allez au premier
des combinaisons une fois que vous avez
fini votre journée juste vous les
remettez dans les vestiaires ça
ressemble à quoi les combinaisons
de spécial oui mais quelle couleur tu
veux quelle couleur tu choisis la
couleur
vous deux vous approchez du gars alors
bonjour oui nous sommes les amis du
spolium une association
loi 1901
à 1901
qu'est-ce que vous voulez et donc
aujourd'hui nous avons une journée
patrimoine et ce bâtiment est en classé
la le maire de d'iridis nous a proposé
de devenir musique
très commune là on vient de faire tout
le centre de jerrydice
vous nous connaissez j'imagine jamais
entendu parler mais les amis du spolium
c'est les anciens les anciens qui
bâtissent et donc chaque année on vient
ce recueillir
quand même mais vous n'êtes pas au
courant de la fête
sinon j'appelle Lara en fait c'est ça
directement parce que là c'est pas
possible on va pas fou ok
vous voulez rentrer visiter l'usine ah
bah là c'est pour préparer la journée du
patrimoine forcément qui a lieu alors vu
que tu as parlé de Lara il a pris un peu
peur tu vas faire un g de mentir
convaincre avec plus de 20% et
bien
[Rires]
mais bien sûr bien sûr prenez le temps
que vous voulez
est-ce que je peux avoir votre carte
s'il vous plaît parce que voilà merci
merci
voilà parfait
oui oui je vous la rends ne vous
inquiétez pas et je voulais laisser un
mot à Lara pour vous dire que c'est quoi
votre David mais merci David madame
couperose allons-y
vous rentrez l'usine ok vous deux vous
êtes dans les vesti en train de vous
changer est-ce que vous voulez faire
quelque chose dans ces vestiaires ou pas
il y a plein d'occasions il y a déjà ou
pas vous êtes juste vous deux il y a
plein de cases
[Rires]
ok
faites moi j'ai dites moi celui qui fait
le score le plus bas il va trouver
quelque chose 28 54
œil de lynx
merci un haïku
c'est un papier à l'attention de Madame
gouttière s je vous fais pas l'accent
si vous souhaitez revoir votre fille
vivante ne parler de ce message à
personne point rendez-vous seul écrin
majuscule dans la clairière au centre de
la forêt du Sud-Ouest pardon sud-est
du Sud-Est au centre de la forêt du
Sud-Est d'iridis dans trois jours
je vous ai dit ça aille ou le truc
rendez-vous seul dans la clairière au
centre de la forêt du Sud-Est d'iridis
dans trois jours amener 500 Irois si
vous voulez récupérer votre fille et un
blanc de dinde non c'est bon
si quelqu'un d'autre vient elle meurt si
vous ne venez pas seul elle meurt si
vous ne venez pas elle meurt si vous
n'amenez pas l'argent dans la bonne
devise elle meurt si elle meurt elle
meurt pardon
un symbole en dessous symbole d'une lune
représentée en noir avec autour des
petits cercles de d'une plante que je
qualifierai d'Olivier mais après voilà
on n'est pas on n'est pas secteur
je vous laisse admirer de romarin
c'est encore un peu plus compliqué
peut-être 500 hirois
ça fait combien de jours de travail ça
fait 50 heures de travail 50 heures
c'est beaucoup beaucoup
est-ce qu'on peut arriver nous dans
l'usine alors vous vous allez pouvoir
vous balader un peu où vous voulez dans
l'usine en gros c'est un peu indiqué
vous deux vous allez aller voir Henri ou
alors vous sortez vous les croisez vous
les suivez vous préférez faire quoi
on va avec le bas peuple non
on les croise on leur explique
eux ils nous racontent oui
donc du coup moi je trouve ce que je
propose c'est qu'on reste ensemble et en
fait on organise comme si vous étiez des
employés vu que maintenant vous allez
combinaisons comme si vous étiez les
employés ici et que nous on vous
accompagne
très bien
mais donc nous ce que vous voulez pas si
vous voulez faire une journée de boulot
pour boss peut-être poser des questions
faut quand même pas qu'on reste trop
longtemps dans les parages il y a une
Lara un peu les nerfs
[Musique]
on est dans une usine soit vraiment
en fait c'est quoi on doit on doit
récupérer du spolium à Bâle et se barrer
qu'est-ce qu'on trouve
si on veut aider le général quoi
Henri quand même parce que imagine on
passe devant
vraiment ce serait bien
qu'on sache on peut y aller on revient
quoi mais c'est vrai que là on est aussi
perdu que vous
l'art de savoir ce qu'on fait quoi
on regarde le machin les murs
d'être à l'intérieur qu'on cherche
il faut bien qu'on rentre dans une pièce
et qu'on cherche quelque chose vous
pouvez commencer à regarder on vous
rejoint
on note des choses on a notre petit
badges voilà
vous le trouvez assez facilement pendant
un peu votre chemin
TDD
et donc il vous accueille dit bonjour on
est pour travailler c'est ça c'est tout
à fait ça d'accord
moi j'ai besoin de main d'oeuvre dans
les cuves parce que là j'ai la quatrième
cuve qui est en train de nous lâcher du
coup faut qu'on répare une façade donc
voilà juste vous vous rendez là-bas il y
a il y a un maître d'oeuvre et vous
dirigera sur qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
ça marche simplement très bien la cuve
direction il vous explique en gros c'est
là vous passez à côté des labos oui et
c'est après ok après le labos
merci Monsieur Henri
merci Chef donc là on repart que Dieu
vous bénisse
on les retrouve et on leur dit écoutez
il y a au moins d'élabos des cuves donc
c'est bien là qu'on produit
on discute on essaie de
comprendre la température
vous leur dites où sont les labos en
passant oui il va ensemble et il
s'arrête au
laboards
blouse blanche qui sont en train de
faire des petites manipulations qui vous
regardent bonjour je peux vous aider oui
bonjour bonjour nous a dit que le labo
aujourd'hui était ouvert pour pour
inspection
nous sommes là pour alors vérifier que
tout est en or pour votre sécurité tout
à fait c'est la dhccp très simplement
donc là c'est la visite annuelle donc
moi je m'appelle David j'ai voilà je
t'ai donné
et normalement vous faites comme si nous
n'étions pas là on veut pas vous gêner
dans votre travail on est juste là pour
s'assurer que tout est au norme et c'est
vraiment là
DHCP voilà la DHCP DHCP donc c'est
vraiment des contrôles de routine aucune
inquiétude à avoir par contre on va
juste vous poser quelques questions
donc vous là-bas je pourrais me faire
quelqu'un ok dis oui oui est-ce que vous
sentez bien au travail sur une échelle
de 1 à 10
c'est pour ça que vous faites à la CCI
vous faites des trucs comme ça non
[Rires]
ça c'est bien ça c'est bien d'accord et
vos relations avec les collègues tout ça
thcp oui non non mais c'est bien de
répondre
donc 7 et donc avec votre collègue de 0
à 10 vos proches dans bien je dirais 8 9
8 9
alors maintenant c'est simplement le
prenez pas mal c'est vraiment juste du
test un petit peu basique voilà
[Musique]
c'est qu'on a on a on a reçu quelques
quelques alertes au niveau du de la
recette du spolium et de nouvelles odeur
oui voilà enfin quelque chose qui serait
anormal et on aimerait juste vérifier si
tout est ce que la recette a changé ce
que vous avez fait un changement au
niveau des chimistes est-ce que
nous on a juste comme tâche de respecter
le protocole petit et voilà le protocole
petit parce que justement nous c'est
vraiment le protocole petit la DHCP le
finance d'ailleurs la DHCP le protocole
petit donc ce qu'on aimerait bien faire
à partir de là c'est juste avoir accès à
votre version ou deux pas tout à fait
vous êtes vous vous appliquez le
protocole exactement
vous avez une fiche
vous le connaissez par coeur ou vous
avez un classeur
le but c'est juste suivre faire une
batterie de test pour s'assurer de que
le spolium soit fabriqué sans sans
problème
d'inflammation lors de la fabrication
d'accord pour nous ce serait le plus
simple surtout ne pas vous faire perdre
votre temps ce serait qu'on puisse
vérifier cette dernière phase de test
effectivement voilà parce que le but
c'est vraiment pas de voilà la
production
on a un temps assez limité
du coup vous les regardez en train de
faire leur test alors là
voir si le protocole petit ce qui a
est-ce qu'il y a une erreur mais
peut-être d'impression enfin une erreur
humaine et c'est pas du tout c'est
vraiment là c'est vraiment un test il y
a un souci dans les dernières livraisons
de de de spolium il y a une odeur
l'odeur qui n'est pas agréable on a eu
des plantes de
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise
donc est-ce qu'on peut voir ce protocole
petit aux feuilles de travail
il te sort un classeur avec marqué voilà
c'est toutes les tous qu'on suit en fait
d'accord très bien
rapidement on le connaît mais voilà vous
vous oui je vais je vais regarder ça
enfin je j'ai ma fiche je dois juste
voilà cocher voir si tout est en règle
voilà ils font des batteries de test en
gros donc ils prennent des éléments un
par un ils font plein de trucs donc moi
je regarde je regarde ok tu regardes bon
tu vois déjà le protocole petit du coup
ok du coup c'est en gros pour
t'expliquer basiquement c'est juste une
liste de tests en référence à un
concierge qui est mort il y a très
longtemps parce que il y avait pas eu
assez de
ça avait pas été assez méticuleux dans
la batterie de test préalable à la
création disponium du coup il y avait un
accident et un certain Frédéric petit
est décédé lors de cet accident du coup
il a donné naissance au sport
qu'est-ce qui est le mieux
au protocole petit du coup qui est donc
simplement une batterie test pour
s'assurer que jamais il n'y ait plus
d'accident lors de la création de
spawium d'accord et à côté de ça du coup
tu trouves
là
synthèse complète du podium d'accord
donc là je
donc c'est dans le classeur je la prends
et je subtilise je la subtilise mais
sans enfin l'air de rien oui juste voilà
je prends toute une bonne liasse de
documents de de classeur j'en prends un
peu plus quoi
d'accord je peux avoir d'autres
documents
donc j'en prends pas mal et je les mets
dans mon intérieur de veste parce que
c'est à ça que ça sert c'est une petite
photo
je sais plus si on m'a dit si je pouvais
faire des photos ou pas mais
clic-clac et je la mets quand même je
suis petit large
voilà
et là je me retourne aujourd'hui bon
écoutez alors moi je ne vois rien dans
le classeur ça m'a l'air vraiment
je pense que ça vient des paysans le
problème
des paysans des paysans non
conférence
je ne sais pas où est la source du
problème peut-être les paysans comme
vous les appelez je ne sais pas mais
effectivement
j'imagine qu'on va peut-être aller voir
dans l'autre étape de dans les cuves ça
vient peut-être des cuves c'est ça ok
bah écoutez merci beaucoup bonne journée
du coup voilà
super
donc là petite check de
vous embrasser là
vous avez une petite équipe la you
[Rires]
trouver une petite équipe
donc avec
un contremaître une fois et un homme qui
sont en train de regarder la queue
à côté de lui à côté d'eux je mets les
mains dans le dos comme ça et je regarde
avec
bonjour
[Musique]
on a été embauché par Monsieur Henry
d'accord pour vous aider
faudrait qu'on le remplace pour éviter
que ça lâche
parce que nous on n'est pas du coup on
n'est pas du coup le spolium liquide
c'est là qu'on les mélange en fait quand
je les laisse reposer avant de les
les mettre en batterie ou en bidon
reposer mais combien de temps c'est
peut-être pour ça que ça use comme ça à
l'écu c'est pas moi qui gère ça mais
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans le Spadium pour
que ça abîme les cuves comme ça
c'est un moment faut bien remplacer
ouais mais est-ce que si on manipule le
spodium en réparant la cuve il faut
qu'on mette des gants c'est dangereux
est-ce qu'on devrait mettre par exemple
un masque et des gants
je travaille jamais
j'ai travaillé jamais sans mon blanc de
dinde vous auriez du blanc dedans
expliquer nous ce qu'on doit faire du
coup il te montre un peu les trucs qu'il
faut remplacer et tout bon tu travailles
manuel en rose
l'enlever mettre le neuf l'assemblée
c'est juste long et chiant mais c'est
pas dur donc on commence à s'y mettre on
guette du coin de l'oeil les collègues
parce que bon là on est un peu
en fait j'ai pas fait de ma vie
un peu de désassembler vous allez vous
attaquer à réassembler vous voyez les
deux rentrer dans la pièce
on a décidé de voilà de fusionner les
associations
alors est-ce qu'ils sont seuls dans les
cuves du coup il y a E2 un contremaître
un homme et une femme qui travaille du
coup ils sont une équipe de 5 en fait en
comptant les deux là d'accord
ce sont des choses à nous dire
[Rires]
on arrive près des gens qui gèrent le
truc là bonjour je suis David
chichois
tu peux lire
de la dhccp on vient d'élaborentin là
donc on est descendu dans les cuves
parce que donc on a la recherche c'est
d'une odeur d'une odeur voilà c'est ça
un problème d'odeur
sur la résultat du spolium donc on a été
voir les laborantin de nos tests
et pas de problème donc moi j'ai donné
envie de coté des laborantin l'huile de
moyenne sur donc pas de problème a
priori à ce niveau là
au marché ça change
est-ce que au niveau des cubes vous
faites quelque chose différente ces
derniers temps
possible pour le coup on les remplace
juste des pièces quand on sent que elle
risque de lâcher mais donc rien vous
avez dit sans quand on sent
un feeling plus qu'une odeur très bien
donc rien d'anormal ces derniers temps
pas juste à part ce plan là qu'on est en
train de remplacer mais je pense pas que
ça est-ce que ça vient pas de vos
producteurs des matériaux des fameux
paysans
qui testent c'est pas mon travail
est-ce que vous avez changé ça vient
d'où vos ingrédients pour pour le
spolium en ce moment c'est les mêmes
qu'avant c'est pas moi qui gère
[Musique]
je fais il y a moyen que vous nous
sortiez parce que on s'emmerde quoi
juste je glisse à Gloria
on va avoir juste besoin de vous
emprunter deux personnes
bah eux deux pour porter des caisses
c'est très lourd et bon vu nos grands
âges on peut plus permettre ça oui oui
on adore porter des caisses alors il y a
une sciatique et moi j'ai ma hanche qui
flanche donc si vous voulez bien si vous
êtes un événement
dans dans quel cadre pour te séquestres
dans le cadre de votre petit c'est donc
la DHCP école du patrimoine 19
00 c'est comme on le disait on va pas
refaire tout le blabla mais c'est
vraiment contrôle de routier d'accord
on a fait une heure de travail donc vous
serez payer seulement pour une heure si
vous
la tronche en fait d'accord
tout le monde est-ce qu'on peut noter
plus 10 du coup
comme ça se prononce plus tard
merci
très bien donc on les suit on fait
semblant de porter des caisses
imaginaires du coup
de la cuisine
7 9 8 alors vous avez trouvé chose
laboratoire en papier
je croyais que vous parlez de des notes
d'évaluation au niveau de la montre
tout va bien tout va bien
non vous savez des fois ça vient ça part
ces choses-là alors
4k2 vous avez une recette
je vous dis je vais vous dire ça
m'intéresse vraiment pas c'est du podium
la dernière fois
parce que si on trouve d'où vient le
spolium d'où il est récolté mais c'est
pour ça que je voulais dire
la recette de synthèse de ça oui mais
des trucs de synthèse ils sont ils
viennent d'où mais on s'en fout on s'en
fout le général il veut la recette
au moins je pense qu'il faut faire
plaisir à personne et que on pense à
nous n'oublions pas quand même madame
gouttière
ce soir ça se passe c'est dans 3 jours
mais on sait pas à partir de quand même
des ennuis d'une autre personne
on est déjà assez dans la sauce
panique alors peut-être qu'on pourrait
juste sortir quelle est la sortir quelle
est notre projet
on sort et qu'est-ce qu'on fait voilà
commençons par sortir est-ce que alors
on pourrait sortir
vulnérable
dedans
que vous mentez d'être désinspecteurs
depuis le début ce serait pas plus de
sécurité dans le marché au milieu des
gens
on va où on va dans un autre village
vous retrouver
[Rires]
à Gaston et nous renvoie là où on était
c'est ça ah oui le Gaston
il a juste dit j'en ai pour une semaine
après on peut lui demander on peut
moi mon scénario idéal mais bon on est
en équipe
moi j'ai pas oublié cette chaire
Hélène qui vit à Gaïa et qui apparemment
à Gaïa il y a des autres scientifiques
est-ce que c'est pas des scientifiques
qui du bien moi c'est le labo souterrain
qui m'intéresse
moi je
j'aurais bien voulu repérer une
raffinerie pour pour Flappy vous vous
souvenez c'est Amélie quoi
dans cette ville oui ça aurait pu soude
ça a très bien marché pour nous donc là
on est nous on est confiant parce que
donc
nous il nous faut des scientifiques mais
il y a aussi
à part la raffinerie de Flappy là c'est
vrai que c'était pas très intéressant
vous voyez il faut être un peu
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça serait intéressant
d'avoir la recette finale de Flappy
pour l'utiliser dans le présent
exactement après ça qu'il nous faut des
moyens de marchander donc de mettre la
pression
pour ça que quand on était sur le marché
ça aurait été bien peut-être de ramener
quelque chose qu'il n'y a pas ailleurs
alors on parle du chantage
est-ce qu'il y aura des
je sais pas faut aller parler aux gens
je répète mon avis c'est qu'on se casse
si on vote mon pote va vers
vos chantiers les paysans ou quoi là
c'est quoi le
chanteur
mais il paraît oui des fois
on y va du coup oui
mais moi je pense que les ingrédients
en sortant de l'usine vous êtes attendus
par trois policiers
qui vous demande de vous de les suivre
on rentre dans l'usine
on est tous on était à tous les quatre
ou quoi là ouais
la tuile alors il s'avère que je sais
très bien faire la morte alors du coup
je m'allonge par terre et je fais
attention
ils prennent chacun un bras et on part
et on dit une employée poussez-vous il
faut que ça soigne voilà c'est ça
on va s'en occuper laissez-nous mais
suivez-nous non non mais vous non non il
faut qu'on s'en occupe maintenant là
c'est une urgence c'est la position
latérale de sécurité mais c'est la DHCP
vous êtes devant l'entrée ils vous
bloque la sortie de l'usine mais vous
voyez bien qu'elle souffre ce sera votre
responsabilité si elle meurt
ah oui si elle meurt elle meurt voilà
parce que ça on sait ouais on a bien
retenu Pierre-Alain appelez Lara
tout à fait bon
ça marche pas les communications
[Musique]
et le maire vous accueille l'air un
petit peu grave je refais la morte non
[Musique]
vous rentrez dans le bureau vous êtes 4
le maire est assis à son bureau il y a
deux personnes qui se postent des deux
côtés de la porte et la troisième sort
donc des trois policiers qui sont venus
le bien il vous demande qu'est-ce que
vous faites dans ce village
moi je suis venu travailler
j'ai travaillé déjà est-ce que vous vous
connaissez de ce qu'on m'a dit oui on a
fait du covoiturage oui oui pour revenir
à
vous seriez du blanc de dinde
merci Monsieur dans votre magnifique
village merci Gilles cité que dis-je
centre cet article
de cette contrée je voudrais d'abord
vous remercier pour votre sens
de la mission
parce que vous savez moi j'étais
président de CCI
[Musique]
comme ça parce que c'est pas facile tous
les jours
c'est vrai que oui elle est très
problématique cette Bourgogne j'imagine
j'imagine et puis les tensions quand on
est à la tête d'autant de oui production
industrielle puis les pillages
dites-moi dites moi en plus les pillages
oui bah forcément vous doutez bien que
si on a tous les commerçants du coin qui
viennent il y a aussi des gens qui
veulent en profiter illégalement ah ça
c'était ah je vous plains mais bon c'est
un problème que je
règle difficilement mais bon c'est pas
pour ça que j'ai envie de parler avec
vous vous êtes des aigles rouges
alors là c'est bien la première fois que
qu'on nous dit ça vraiment
voilà alors plutôt marmotte
je connais l'Aigle noir si vous voulez
je peux vous la chanter
[Musique]
vous êtes pas des aigles rouges nous
sommes des indépendants et du coup
pourquoi est-ce que vous venez fouiller
l'usine
fouiller
d'horizon oui vous venez fouiller
l'usine de spolium alors nous on est
venu travailler
et nous c'était vraiment dans le cadre
d'un contrôle tout ce qu'il y a de plus
basiques c'est juste nos clients
qui sont basés à
Gaïa
mais aussi enfin dans toute la contrée
voilà nous ont demandé d'aller voir à
l'usine pour
avoir des informations mais rien de rien
de rien une confidentiel c'était
vraiment l'une des informations
peut-être ah mais des informations
simplement parce qu'il y a une odeur
dans le Spadium
et cette odeur nous inquiète il inquiète
nos clients donc on est venu ici pour
tout simplement avoir la source de cet
auteur c'est vrai que ça puait
c'est pas vu le marché
je veux pas être irrespectueux mais bon
à horizon ça s'appuyait pas quoi là
c'est vrai qu'on arrive dans votre
village
quel est ce lien là de pourquoi en fait
c'est quoi c'est qui
menacent et que bizarrement en cas de
personnes viennent d'horizon rentre dans
l'usine oui vous savez monsieur je hais
les Aigles rouges beaucoup plus que vous
je vais vous le prouver les Aigles
rouges ils nous mettent dans le pétrin
merci beaucoup
il n'en loupe pas une
[Musique]
c'est terrible
chaque fois tous les contrôles qui ont
fait quoi les aiglesias
donc vraiment on est dans le même bateau
ici donc dans ce cas je peux vous
demander de
vider vos poches
oui moi j'ai encore un petit peu
d'argent
[Musique]
du coup comment ça vous fouiller un peu
plus au corps et du coup il trouve un
papier il sort il est pas sur le bureau
du maire et le maire il te regarde
qu'est-ce que c'est
la recette du spolium
je préfère être prisonnière là où il y a
un arc-en-ciel que là-bas c'est vrai
bon on avancera pas ils vont nous
je le connais pas beaucoup hein
je suis vraiment venu travailler je suis
artisan bah moi aussi parce que vous
voulez on les a trouvés à l'usine ils
travaillaient à l'usine
c'est tout moi je les connais pas après
oui en même temps il faut se ressenti de
l'usine pile en même temps
ils se sont présentés comme de la
déchets acpp et il m'a dit Monsieur on a
besoin d'apporter les pièces moi je
reviens pas moi ce truc là ils m'ont dit
venez il faut porter une caisse je porte
une caisse et je sors je me fais arrêter
bon comprenez ma oui d'accord bon on
leur fait la confidence
je tente le tout pour le tout monsieur
est-ce que vous aimez les agitateurs
magnétiques et là je prends ma valise et
je m'adresse à lui
n'aimez pas les Aigles rouges nous non
plus nous sommes en fuite et et je
découvrais
vous vous avez bien les Aigles rouges
moi je connais pas et je les connais pas
non plus
nous font du chantage et pour tout vous
dire il n'y a pas d'odeur dans le
Spadium ça
rien d'autre à dire
oui je joue du pipeau
il ne nous ont détenus il nous menacent
et ils essayent de bonne nous faire
travailler gratos enfin pour un petit
peu mais pour eux enfin pas vraiment
parce que si vous voulez nous n'avions
jamais l'intention de leur livrer quoi
que ce soit
dans ce cas pourquoi une fois venu à
iridis vous êtes quand même aller dans
cette usine de spodium pour récupérer la
synthèse
pour travailler pour ma part je tiens
si vous voulez la vie
on essaie d'avancer chaque matin on se
dit il faut faire quelque chose
c'est ça et puis il y a toujours des
problèmes qui vous arrivent et on y
trouve des solutions puis c'est aussi
pour s'occuper la solution d'un autre
problème avec le général Beaulieu une
personne forte désagréable c'était de
lui dire qu'on allait à iridis une fois
aéridie se trouve la recette maintenant
nous nous sommes heureux et nous venons
à vous
des beaux lieux il sait pas qu'on est là
mais en tout cas on est venu faire on
vous donne la recette
j'avais déjà la recette oui mais comme
ça vous signale qu'il y a des voilà
c'est votre cuisine elle est pas
forcément très bien gardé
si moi j'arrive à voir votre recette
imaginez les exemples
c'est facile de reconnaître vous vous
doutez bien que on a quand même quelques
problèmes c'est à dire que nous on est
la seule usine de la région donc on
fournit le spodium de toute la région
sauf que la population elle est
croissante donc cette usine au bout d'un
moment elle commençait à atteindre ses
limites de production et les Aigles
rouges nous mettent de plus en plus de
pression pour récupérer cette production
quitte à nous menacer de raser le
village
[Musique]
de discuter beaucoup avec le village
d'amaryllis qui pour le coup eux sont de
grands partenaires économiques de nous
mais les Aigles rouges
pose problème à nouveau parce que Maryse
ne veut pas se fâcher avec les ébules
rouges mais justement nous nous allions
aller voir Gaïa parce que nous avons
Hélène une amie une amie donc qui voilà
qui nous a dit que c'était à Gaillac il
fallait aller donc nous on allait aller
à Gaïa avec cette recette justement pour
voir ce qui se passait là-bas
tout simplement nous si on peut éviter
de retourner à Elixia
une semaine
[Musique]
pas trop est-ce que est-ce que vous
savez faire des voyages dans le temps
est-ce que vous avez cette technologie
là
d'accord
avec votre votre
usine
avec beaucoup plus de choses que mon
usine parce que bon développement
économique tout ça c'est à dire que là
on est à deux doigts d'entrer en guerre
et vous vous doutez bien qu'un village
contre une armée entière un peu
compliqué de l'ouvrier deux vieux et
enfin bon est-ce que vous attendez de
nous on le fait
il est fatigué je les connais pas je les
connais pas
c'est que vous preniez conscience de vos
actes et que vous vous rendez compte que
si vous livrez
cette synthèse de spodium n'auront plus
aucun moyen de pression sur horizon et
ils pourront juste venir récupérer ne
vous inquiétez pas nous sommes avec vous
on comprend est-ce que
on va vous aider forcément que je peux
développer cette synthèse m'assurer
qu'elle ne quitte pas ce village mais
tout à fait prenez donc
[Musique]
là en passant j'écris très rapidement
la recette sur un petit carnet que
j'avais justement dans mes malaise je
vous l'avais pas dit à la base celle-là
tu nous feras un jet de bullshitomètre
d'être excellent alors
[Rires]
sur
la discrétion 55
donc du coup super esprit je peux avoir
votre parole que si cette synthèse ne
quitte n'attendra pas les oreilles du
général bolus
je vous offre une chanson parfait
moi j'ai des gros problèmes dans ce
village vous l'aurez compris si vous
êtes digne de confiance je pense que je
peux vous parler de certaines choses
enfin après on peut aussi je sais partir
moi je veux aider ce village à se
développer
est-ce que nous pose des problèmes elle
est influente mais c'est une femme bien
plus influente que moi je pense possible
et bien pourquoi donc par la force et la
peur on est plus facilement
l'influence que juste dans le respect
je pense peut-être que je suis un peu
trop gentil avec mon peuple mais
toujours est-il que actuellement Lara
fait effrétout la population
et un pose des taxes gigantesques sur
les marchands
c'est en fait c'est raquette c'est elle
qui
contrôle
monopolise complètement le commerce
alors que iridis est une ville un
village de commerce
du coup ça freine énormément
le commerce c'est ça
l'évolution du village pardon
je me doute que vous vous allez rien
ne vous alliez jamais avec Lara vous
avez l'air d'être des bonnes personnes
oui on n'aurait jamais fait ça vraiment
si on l'avait proposé on aurait dit non
oui on nous l'a proposé et on est tout
de suite d'ailleurs je me suis un peu
interposée parce que parce que bon on
peut se laisser tenter mais tout de
suite j'ai dit non les amis vraiment
c'est pas possible quoi
non ouais
[Musique]
quitter le divage hypothétiquement alors
moi ce qu'il faudrait passer pour
l'éviter par exemple
je suis pas sûr que vous puissiez
vraiment l'hériter
bien que oui est-ce qu'on peut j'ai
quelques forces de police la moitié sont
corrompue donc à bien que c'est
compliqué peut-être les deux avec nous
là d'ailleurs
bravo les gars non mais comment on peut
vous aider parce que si on l'aide ben
oui ça améliore la situation
mais par contre
[Musique]
est-ce que juste c'est très intéressant
parce que vous racontez mais parlons de
choses plus voilà est-ce que vous avez
entendu parler d'un laboratoire
souterrain dans votre ville
non pas spécialement et d'une ancienne
raffinerie une ancienne raffinerie
ça ne me dit rien je peut-être que vous
parlez de miratria comment vous écrivez
ça comme sur la carte
je pense pas qu'ils avaient une
raffinerie mais pour le coup si vous
voulez aller chercher de l'ancien je
pense que c'est là-bas qu'il faut aller
vu que ils ont tous fini par immigrer
jusqu'à iridis
ouais mais nous les immigrés je suis pas
trop si quel genre de problème
ils disent que la ville est hantée mais
ça me semble un peu absurde
pour cette raison je trouve ça bizarre
mais d'accord
bon est-ce qu'on peut vous aider d'une
manière ou d'une autre ou est-ce qu'on
peut juste y aller ça me paraît si vous
voulez m'aider oui je sais pas c'est pas
qu'on veut mais bon
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire qu'on
peut vous rendre un service voilà
on circule comme ça peut-être que si
vous trouvez un levier de négociation
avec les Aigles rouges pour pour nous
permettre de garder
indépendance sur le sujet et s'assurer
qu'il ne nous attaque pas ça pourrait
être pas mal est-ce qu'ils aiment la
dinde
vous savez je suis pas sûr que des
aigles aiment la dinde alors là vous
seriez surpris
vous avez pas une petite mission tu te
dis plus mission diplomatique
est-ce que vous vous avez connaissance
de de transport qui nous amène qui nous
amènerait à Gaïa et à
maryliss je sais pas faudrait demander
aux marchand je suppose que il est
d'accord il vous vendrait sûrement
des places ok parfait sinon bah il y a
aussi ce
feu de joie horrible qu'il faudrait
arrêter un jour pourquoi ce qui
se passe jolie
mais bon il consomme des quantités
monstrueuses de spolium pour éclairer
à peu près autant qu'à lampadaire au
final ou que quelques lampadaires et
alors que on est en train de galérer à
produire du spolium pour pour faire
vivre la population oui mais le beau
vous y pensez au beau
bon les canaux
de vivre non non mais vous avez raison
mais oui oui le gâchis si vous voulez si
vous trouvez une solution pour quoi que
ce soit n'hésitez pas
je voudrais compenserai évidemment si
vous aidez
là on parle
juste vous connaissez l'étymologie de
votre nom de ville
ça m'intrigue
[Musique]
[Rires]
avec tes origines grecques
vous avez l'air d'être des personnes de
confiance je vous ai mis au courant j'ai
récupéré de documents je vous ai mis au
courant que vous risquez de déclencher
une guerre donc j'espère que vous
n'allez pas faire une telle chose mais
en responsabilité nous allons bien sûr
nous restreindre d'engager toutes sortes
de conflictualité voilà j'espère bien en
tout cas je n'ai pas les les moyens de
vous en empêcher à part par la force
mais je sais pas ce que j'ai envie de
prôner dans ce village d'accord très
bien très bien
merci Monsieur Merci pour cette soirée
donc en fait nous à part Gaston on peut
compter sur personne d'autre quoi
il a déjà la solution faites des cours
bien à Elixia on se fait on se fait
souffrir
mais on sait qu'on est qu'on est revenu
dans le passé parce que le protocole
petit machin tout ça on sait qu'on a
réussi à faire ça donc on a réussi à
collaborer avec Gaston d'une manière ou
d'une autre
c'est pas comment ça marche non c'est
trop compliqué
moi je suis toujours David d'aller à
marillière non mais je suis bien
d'accord je pense que c'est une belle
torche c'est le moment de la montrer au
monde
vous sortez
donc du de la mairie
il y a un panneau qui vous intrigue un
peu où il y a marqué
la boutique de Bozo avec une flèche pas
moi voilà
ça prend un une direction vous voulez
aller où sinon
on va voir des marchands et on leur
demande le prochain transport qui part
pour un mariage
peut-être qu'ils auront de la dinde je
me colle un petit creux
de toi
commercial tout ça OK
qu'est-ce que vous faites niveau torche
de spoilium donc toi tu en as une oui
l'autre c'est qui qui la prend
vous avez pas besoin de les mettre mais
j'ai juste besoin de savoir qui est la
deuxième
[Musique]
ok
tu vas suivre les panneaux vers la
boutique de Bozo vous vous rendez vers
la place qui est un petit peu loin mais
c'est assez facile de repérer
sur le trajet de la boutique
ou dans une ruelle en tant que quelqu'un
qui te fait qui te demande de venir
je lui dis il est tout seul
[Rires]
et je viens du coup
tu veux
[Rires]
un mode de torche
un mode
genre on peut changer les couleurs et
tout pour
pour tout défoncer quoi
15 euros le mode tu peux utiliser autant
que tu veux peu importe
à mes collègues et je me dis que ce
serait peut-être pas très raisonnable
et alors si plein d'émotions que je lui
tends l'argent
ok
j'ai du flouze aussi pour mettre avec de
l'ancien flouze
il te dit ok bah je te prends 10 0,1 et
5 anciennes OK
il te donne un mode de torche c'est un
truc que il te montre en gros comment ça
s'installe ça s'installe sur le bas de
la torche
il y a un bouton
et en fait quand tu l'appuies genre il
te montre sur sa torche à lui du coup
j'aurais tellement de comment ça marche
sur sa torche mais en fait tu appuies
sur un bouton ça fait brûler très fort
dans sa brille beaucoup et après il
respire dedans
il a l'air défoncé
avec ça mais voilà
t'inquiète t'inquiète
est-ce que je peux essayer sa torche
avant la mienne
comme ça quoi genre il te montre comment
ça marche gratuit
de puissance de fou
en termes de gameplay dehors du jeu en
fait ton prochain lancer là dans les
quelques minutes qui suivent après avoir
fait ça tu auras plus 30%
bon là en l'occurrence tu vas pas faire
de lancer ça ne sert à rien et par
contre vu que tu as respiré tu vas
t'ajouter une compétence spéciale
addiction oh yes bravo
ok merci c'était bien
tu essuies un peu surexcité et tu te
sens surpuissante je suis bien je suis
bien vous avez bien fait de m'abandonner
[Musique]
si je veux voir Bozo mais j'ai
complètement oublié je continue
pendant ce temps vous
vous atteignez la place
vous chercher quelque chose
spécifiquement juste vous de mon côté je
fais juste le tour des commerçants alors
en demandant
est-ce que vous savez s'il y a enfin
voilà en usant de mon
bagou pour leur dire ah oui j'aimerais
voyager jusqu'à un mari 10
pas besoin de poser de questions machin
je vais juste la barre vous savez c'est
plein le business machin et est-ce que
vous pouvez le faire pour
aller
20 ok bon truc quoi pour combien pour
combien de personnes pour quatre
personnes 20 pour les vins pour vin pour
LES QUATRE pardon 20 pour les quatre
pour les 4
allez
c'est le seul truc que je sais faire
OK
mais on peut peut-être demander à
quelqu'un d'autre
c'est peut-être le prix le prix c'est le
prix quoi voilà très bien
demain matin oh ben non
bavards
me mettre dans la voiture et partir ça
va être pareil pour tout le monde quoi
alors là je vends jusqu'à ce soir ce
soir je remballe et demain je pars
est-ce qu'on essaie de partir tout de
suite tout de suite ou pas déjà il faut
attendre
de luxe
[Musique]
vous mettez d'accord avec ce gars du
coup ou pas
c'est 20 30
ça peut ça peut s'arranger
on se retrouve demain avec l'argent et
je vous ferai le trajet avec plaisir
d'accord très bien
aussi où est-ce qu'on peut trouver un
hôtel ou un hôtel il t'indique en gros
il y a un hôtel restaurant qui s'appelle
le comptoir ok qui à proximité de la
place juste très rapidement pour gérer
cette partie là mais on prend des quatre
nuits et alors juste avant que vous
partiez au moment de partir petit j'ai
d'intelligence tous les trois
15 33 sur
40 ok
nous d'abord vous c'est bon toi tu vas
vouloir acheter trop deux objets pardon
mais ils font tu as envie de faire des
emplettes
des trucs archéologiques
un coussin en poil de Lama
dis deux trucs que tu veux acheter dans
ce marché
et bien moi je voudrais quelque chose
qui est fabriqué ici donc je sais pas si
d'accord
quelque chose
je vais prendre du podium déjà de 1 ok
voilà je prends une pile ou plus de pile
j'en prends une ok c'est 5 pieds
donc une pile qui me fait je vous
rappelle que je sais pas compter
du coup ok
donc ça fait ça ok d'accord et ton
deuxième achat c'est mon deuxième achat
je sais pas elle est tellement possible
[Musique]
je veux ah non ah non je veux un outil
un outil
qu'est-ce qu'ils font à iridiision du
métal ils ont dû qu'est-ce qu'ils font
ils ont quoi
je veux une pioche
ah non c'est le truc le plus facile à
transporter c'est génial
je veux une petite machette un truc qui
coupe OK
5 moi je la prends pour 5
un petit peu pitié
vous allez quand même pas vendre une
lame émoussé à quelqu'un
95 tu m'as dit c'est bien ça oui à peu
près du coup faut que tu fasses c'est
mort mais non
on va on va
même vous prendre une une petite
batterie de plus de pile si on achète
c'est pas la même personne
monnaie
pas de façon
c'est fait pour des pensées
moi je veux une machine
j'ai une machette
on pratique c'est vrai
pratique ok
mais après la marchandage va être
beaucoup plus simple donc vous vous
rendez vers le comptoir qui est le resto
elle nous a rejoint non elle elle va
chez Bozo
tu arrives chez Gabriel la boutique de
Gabriel Bozo
donc une petite boutique qui ne fait pas
de mine
qui a l'air très jolie à l'intérieur
c'est bien éclairé de toutes les
couleurs c'est toutes les couleurs
bien éclairé chez vous bien
un petit homme de une cinquantaine
d'années il est assez derrière son
comptoir quand il te regarde
il se pose des questions sur toi
ils font des sourcils un peu
je regarde ce qu'il vend comme produit
ok en gros il a il vend des réfracteurs
de torche de spolium
changer la couleur
je ressors
[Rires]
c'est pour ça que la vie elle est
arc-en-ciel parce que le fabricant il
est là
[Rires]
je regarde ma main
vous voyez comme moi
dingue
ah c'est incroyable
et je reste juste je m'assois dans un
coin et je regarde tout ça qui brille
dans la rue ou dans le magasin
je peux vous aider
au revoir monsieur je me lève et je
ressors d'accord
je rejoins les autres ok donc nous on
attend près du feu
comme vous voulez
ok bon de toute façon
vous vous êtes passés au comptoir avait
pris une chambre
alors vous prenez une chambre pour 4 du
coup
pas cher
après si vous voulez en prendre plus
dites moi mais
je me fais un peu régaler
j'avais pas vu le coup de la torche de
luxe là
[Musique]
du coup vous ressortez de du comptoir
parce que si vous voulez déjà aller
dormir mais il est 15h quoi
ça peut être bien
on s'est retrouvé du coup
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de beau
alors j'ai profité des couleurs
j'ai profité des couleurs de la ville
de torche et en fait c'est pour changer
la couleur des torches c'est pour ça que
la ville s'appelle iridis c'est qu'en
fait il y a toutes les couleurs
pourquoi je sais pas imaginer on croise
les Aigles rouges hop on met la torche
en rouge on fait ouais salut ah je peux
vous montrer la route si vous voulez
qu'on y retourne moi je pense ça peut
être intéressant
si j'avais réfléchi j'aurais pu en
acheter
je vais avec eux pour marchander le
marchand de rue
du coup vous faites le trajet inverse un
nouveau je salue mon ami
dans le vide du coup tu fais ça dans une
nouvelle ou la voyez ça lui est une
ruelle
je vais vous poser de comprendre quelque
chose s'est passé d'accord
vous arrivez dans la boutique de Bozo
il vous faut rentrer il te revois il
fait re-bonjour
bonjour vous avez dû voir ma soeur
jumelle qui est passé chez vous tout à
l'heure et elle m'a dit que vous aviez
des réfracteurs c'est bien ça oui
est-ce que c'est combien s'il vous plaît
c'est 10 euros le réfractaire
le réfractaire ils font combien de
couleurs une couleur
[Musique]
acheté 4e offert ou un truc comme ça
je lui demande déjà si c'est une offre
qui existe tu pourras négocier
[Musique]
sur une couleur éventuelle ça va être
compliqué
mais bon on va pas jouer au Power
Rangers
[Rires]
une couleur
c'est je suis je sais pas hein
encore une fois le beau
mais c'est pas la question petite
question off est-ce que le réfractaire
et
est compatible avec le mode je me
défonce ou pas ok
merci
torche
non tout va bien des gros beaux enfants
en fait on est ensemble
mais en fait elle est tunée de partout
[Rires]
du coup moi si on peut juste prendre une
roue une rouge c'est pour se faire
passer pour les Aigles rouges
et qui nous foutent la paix vous lui
dites quoi spécifiquement bon lui dit on
va juste vous prendre un réflexteur
rouge
s'il vous plaît et
parce que
en fait c'est
ta vie mais oui
[Rires]
des représentants pour je fais pas drôle
vous faites pas de rouge
mission du rouge avec du bleu
tu peux pas les avoir mais
on peut prendre de le verre du coup
vous voulez du rouge
[Musique]
[Rires]
on a dit rouge on pensait vert en fait
[Musique]
c'est
ça c'est daltonisme il dit rouge quand
il veut dire vert parce que vous appelez
rouge moi c'est vert
[Musique]
c'est bien ok
alors là je vous tends 20 en ancienne
monnaie c'est ça
[Musique]
les moyennement vert quand même
je suis désolé
en plus ça se casse facilement
bon bah je vais jeter mes dés mais voilà
vous me dites
marchandage voilà
67 vous voyez hein
sur 75 et du coup tu négocies à combien
à deux
avant du coup il te le fait à 7 d'accord
ok bon ça marche à 7 allez c'est parti
je les ai perdu
en fait il y avait un petit trou dans ma
mallette et juste les 10 rois et 5 de
l'ancienne monnaie pouf ils sont tombés
c'est vraiment dommage
mais c'est la vie
ok vous avez un réfracteur de torche si
vous voulez que votre torche soit verte
je le mets sur ma torche de luxe
en fait c'est un truc que tu mets par
dessus et oui quand tu allumes la torche
en fait c'est relié direct ça marche
nickel
oui je le pilote
dessus
c'est magnifique
[Musique]
d'accord
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire
on va à l'hôtel et on dort en 2023 le
lendemain on y va parce que il est
vraiment tout enfin
c'est pas un petit
faut qu'on profite d'être sur place
pour voir un coup cacher
[Musique]
un truc pour les Aigles rouges là pour
leur dire ouh là là
je peux tout de suite
en fait les Aigles rouges il faut qu'on
les trompe pour qu'on leur file un faux
trucs
on peut se faire des
fausses cartes dans un imprimer comme ça
parce que ça nous a bien
donc
je pense qu'on y va juste avec
avec Madame coupros venez madame
[Musique]
allez on y va on va avoir un imprimeur
ok
on se fait faire des cartes avec notre
piscine
et donc du coup on trouve quelqu'un on
fait des petites cartes des petits
machins ok bon ben voilà vous êtes dans
la rue vous êtes devant la boutique
c'est quoi le plan là vous êtes quatre
devant la boutique
le marché on nous a dit il y a tout ce
que vous voulez comme la pièce des
secrets là
on vend un peu de tout mais d'un
imprimeur il faut mais il y a pas de
papier
mais il y a pas des imprimeurs sur le
marché
est-ce qu'il y a un imprimeur sur le
à tout le monde vous retournez au marché
du coup on retourne partout on cherche
un imprimeur on peut la question à tout
le monde se cache pas dans la rue on va
dire vous vous demandez à des gens dans
la rue oui il y a des gens qui vous
disent oui oui il y a des gens qui font
l'imprimerie parfait on y va vous voyez
les deux parties vous vous est-ce que
vous voulez suivez ou pas moi je suis
pas très chaud
je pense qu'on passe pour on n'est pas
dangereux quoi
[Musique]
vous partez dans deux directions
différentes
et
sur le trajet donc vous allez tous enfin
vous deux et vous deux aussi vous allez
vivre la même chose à peu près peu de
choses d'écart donc je vais juste vous
la décrire une fois pour tout le monde
mais vous n'êtes pas ensemble
vous entendez des sifflements
espèce de sifflement qui se répondent un
peu dans la rue et
au même moment les gens s'enfuient
genre les gens que vous croisez dans les
Russes enfuient et vous vous retrouvez
un peu encerclé par un homme moi je m'en
fous
avec des armes contondantes qui vous en
cercle on n'a pas pu avec les gens oui
vous voulez fuir avec les gens qui veut
fuir avec les gens
ok il y en a qui vous attrape et qui
vous rejettent au milieu du cercle vous
spécifiquement ah c'est qui vous deux et
e270
je crois que je connais Fredo c'est une
histoire de street dance j'ai vu des
trucs comme ça dans des films
avec des clous dedans et ils font une
direction
je regarde à la fois la batte et ensuite
la direction
moi je le regarde moi je le regarde elle
tourne la tête quand je
ce que vous faites quelque chose mais il
prend de quelle direction moi je regarde
dans la direction je vois quoi moi je
suis comme ça j'ai bougé
je sors ma torche
lentement
sur je me tourne comme ça sur le retour
j'allume le réfractaire je regarde celui
qui a fait ça avec sa batte dans les
yeux et je fais
les deux guignols
[Musique]
vas-y un peu
la direction est-ce qu'il faut toujours
la même direction
alors où ça parce que nous on a quand
même un rendez-vous à la dhccp oui voilà
moi je suis un peu je suis un peu perdue
je pense qu'on devait aller avec les
gens là qui qui croient pas là-bas non
faites pas attention enfin je sais pas
où ils sont là
oui bon si vous les laissez près du feu
ça ira bien voilà
j'ai l'impression qu'il pleut
avance par là cette direction
par là j'y vais mais en Moonwalk ok donc
tu vas dans la direction
moi je
laisse suis mais en reculant c'est à
dire je suis d'oeil et je fixe
est-ce que le chien
à l'arrière en fait d'un bâtiment
vous avez l'impression qu'il y a pas mal
de gens parce que vous l'entendez vous
entendez qu'il y a pas mal de population
dans ce bâtiment mais vous rentrez un
peu par la porte arrière donc vos fruits
vous êtes avec votre cercle qui
la justice se range il vous laisse
rentrer et vous voyez un autre sac de
personnes avec eux deux qui arrivent en
marche arrière
mais c'est pas mal
il vous invite à rentrer dans ce
bâtiment oui tout à fait il y a des
marches je vous propose qu'on fasse la
pause maintenant très bien si ça vous va
qu'est-ce qu'on va rencontrer là-dedans
on va se faire une petite pause de 5
minutes sur le chat donc on va vous
mettre un petit timer et puis on se
retrouve tout de suite juste le temps
d'aller boire un petit verre d'eau
respirer deux secondes et c'était pour
dire les jambes et on revient tout de
suite pour savoir qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans cette pièce la suite c'est la
rapproche spiruline
[Rires]
du coup donc pour rappel pour ceux qui
ont raté avant la pose nos amis se sont
fait
embarquer un peu de force par des
individus un peu louche dans la rue on a
tenu le terrain
on a Fredo qui a un peu perdu son
sang-froid mais qui c'est un peu fait
rire en même temps
ça avait l'air c'est dommage si vous
avez raté ce moment c'était très drôle
donc vous avez été ramené vous vous êtes
retrouvés dans un bâtiment à l'arrière
d'un bâtiment
et les personnes vous font rentrer dans
ce bâtiment
une fois que vous rentrez dedans c'est
moi retrouver mon bidule j'ai retrouvé
mon bidule si encore
donc les personnes en fait elles
voulaient il y a juste deux personnes
qui vous accompagnent jusqu'à un bureau
où il y a une femme qui est assise les
pieds sur la table avec des grosses
Rangers
qui fume un cigare qui est extrêmement
baraqué elle fait peur vraiment
bonsoir madame
[Musique]
pourquoi vous me cherchiez
mais tout simplement parce qu'on a
entendu parler
un de vos collègues à Alexia et qui nous
a dit de venir vous voir
moi j'y vais Franco franco de port
il nous avait parlé d'une mallette oui
voilà et alors
quand on lui a parlé c'était très confus
il avait l'air
dans un mais presque secondaire
parce que nous a parlé d'une mallette
qui l'aurait perdu et il est venu nous
dire vite chercher voilà alors nous on a
plein de choses à faire c'était
incompréhensible donc voilà je sais pas
trop quoi vous dire avec ça
vous vous êtes vraiment en train de vous
embourber dans votre histoire voilà
personne dont vous parlez
c'est quelqu'un que je respecte
énormément qui fait partie de
de mes partisans depuis extrêmement
longtemps j'ai confiance en lui il m'a
ramené lui-même cette mallette je ne
pense pas qu'il avait tant perdu que ça
et ce qu'il m'a dit c'est plutôt que
vous avez refusé de me donner un coup de
main qui aurait été bien évidemment payé
mais du coup vous m'avez fait perdre de
l'argent
on avait peur de prendre cette on
connaissait pas cette personne mais par
contre on est venu oui bah dans votre
village
quand même et donc vous m'avez fait
perdre de l'argent
c'est pas évidents
de vous et vous voyez sur une chaise il
y a romain dolim
a
qui est complètement ensemble il est
attaché à la chaise et il est il est pas
vraiment
faire attention il est plus très
conscient
il va bien ce garçon est-ce qu'on peut
pas faire un premier soin
là pour vous déranger oui ben moi
écoutez à partir du moment où vous me
remboursez cette dette
de petites minutes là pourquoi c'est
nous qui avons un combo de la charge de
transporter cette mallette à la base
vous connaissez
mais le type d'avant il l'a peut-être
pas fait non plus pourquoi c'est pas lui
qui est réglerait la dette quelque part
tous les gens du monde ne l'ont pas fait
nous on a une bonne raison de pas
l'avoir fait c'est que alors de un je ne
m'appelle pas Hubert
nous avons des des propres soucis et
franchement si tu nous avais confié à la
mallette bah on s'est fait arrêter trois
fois depuis qu'on est ici donc à mon
avis votre palette elle aurait été pas
que
l'équipe la plus fine écoutez madame
Lara Fabian mallette pour malette je
vous propose celle-ci on la vide et
franchement elle est d'une excellente
qualité c'est de cuire de retourner de
vache et également de son veau qui était
élevé sous le pis et qui a été tué avant
qu'il n'atteignent son 13e semaine
anniversaire c'est vraiment le le cuir
le plus tendre que vous verrez de votre
vie franchement c'est une affaire
je m'en fous de votre mallette moi ce
que je veux c'est que vous me remboursez
les 200 0 que vous me devez non mais en
fait
pour essayer d'avoir de l'argent parce
que la fin on va jamais s'en sortir
si vous avez pas l'argent vous propose
de me rendre service ah bah tout de
suite
on peut faire de la lumière verte si
vous voulez d'ailleurs Fredo je vais
faire une démonstration il y a une
personne qui me doit 600 euros parce que
lui aussi il a pas apporté une mallette
non parce que je lui ai prêté de
l'argent ah oui bah lui il a une résonne
de devoir de l'argent par exemple vous
pouvez nous en prêter parce qu'on en a
plus trop est-ce que vous pouvez nous
prêter 200 0 comme ça on vous rembourse
la mallette
de 2000 quand vous doit avec ces deux
sens dans quelques jours on rembourse
bien sûr vous nous laissez quelques
jours on va voilà et puis
sinon comment on va les trouver en fait
nous je suis pas stupide non plus je
vais pas vous laisser fuir
c'est Monsieur Chicheportiche qui
s'occupe de nos finances
voilà lui le business se plaint c'est
nécessite de se déplacer est-ce qu'on
peut vous rembourser en breakdance
moi j'en ai perdu une fois parce que
j'étais pas bien bien là mais il y a des
poils qui se perdent
elle dit bon cette personne c'est
Mélissa gouttière
qui
m'a demandé de toute urgence 500 euros
elle m'a dit qu'elle me rembourser dans
les jours qui venaient et elle sait
volatilisée
alors comme je vous l'ai dit moi quand
je prête de l'argent je m'assure que la
personne ne parte pas en dehors de mon
champ de vision pour être sûr de pouvoir
la retrouver si jamais elle décide de ne
pas payer en l'occurrence je sais
pertinemment qu'il n'a pas quitté iridis
et ses environs mais je n'ai aucune idée
de où elle peut être donc vous l'avez
pas quitté les yeux mais vous savez pas
où aller non j'ai juste surveillé les
sorties de la ville mais non du coup on
peut pas du village pardon
j'ai l'info que c'était 500 hirois et
pas 600 peut-être que ça vous parle
la Confrérie de la lune
si
vous voyez
je vous laisse deux jours 48 heures à
partir d'aujourd'hui de maintenant sinon
quoi
sinon
la ramener si vous préférez mais même si
vous me donnez une information sur sa
localisation ce sera largement suffisant
et je considérais que votre dette sera
effacée OK et nous pourrions pour être
par la suite travailler ensemble nous on
a plutôt
fantastique opportunité merci je propose
si vous
dans 48 heures vous ne l'avez pas trouvé
enfin vous je n'ai pas de nouvelles de
vous tout du moins votre ami Romain là
il y passe et vous je vous traque
pendant ces 48 heures vous quittez pas
iridis alors j'ai quelques conditions
déjà qu'est-ce que vous avez comme info
là sur
sur la dame parce que vous avez quand
même essayé de la chercher vous
peut-être nous guider un peu pourquoi
pas chez elle c'est pas présentée à son
travail depuis qu'elle m'a demandé
l'argent c'est quoi son signe
astrologique
on va la trouver
mais qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a fait cette
elle vous devez de l'argent
je vous a pas dit pourquoi emprunter de
l'argent moi je pose pas de question en
tant que me rembourse et là on m'a pas
rembourse
totalement viable
non mais après voilà
c'est vos secrets bon on va pas vous
embêter on va se mettre voilà à la
recherche
de l'Inde
on sort de bâtiment et sans personne
nous arrête c'est ça là on sort du
bâtiment
quoi que vous dites vous sortez par
rapport à ailleurs soit vous retournez
dans le bar ok
on sort dans la rue et on marche jusqu'à
notre hôtel on se parle en quoi oui OK
je pense il faut qu'on retourne à
l'usine et qu'on interroge les collègues
je suis pas du tout confiance
on va perdre 2 jours à chercher de la
thune on va l'amener et on va se faire
vraiment je dis ça mais de manière
tout hein
on en a quelque chose à faire alors oui
on peut elle a dit que seulement la
moindre information sur la localisation
ça lui suffirait donc moi je dis on
l'envoie dans la forêt puisque nous on
sait que a priori l'argent c'était pour
la formation
on lui dit voilà nous c'est la piste
qu'on a et hop on se casse là
tenez madame
en fait quand tu compares un peu avec la
carte tu te rends compte qu'en fait au
sud-est d'iridis en fait il y a le mon
niveau en fait tu dis que c'est sur ce
flanc du mon niveau ce qu'il y avait ton
site de fouille
si vous avez un rendez-vous seul à
carrière au sang ah oui sud-est d'iris
d'accord
d'accord ah oui donc le rendez-vous est
à l'endroit de du chantier de fouille
que je que je dirais
la clairière ça se trouve c'est
l'ancienne empreinte de la zone de
fouille parce qu'on avait abattu des
arbres pour fouiller là-bas
on peut y aller et après lui donner
l'info quoi on peut même prévenir la
Mélissa
sans doute mais là j'ai l'impression
qu'on est vraiment dans une mission
touristique c'est exactement enfin qu'on
dit rasé non mais parfait
on lui balance l'info et on se casse là
qu'on aille là-bas ma sauce on y va
avant peut-être ça met en danger ah on
peut peut-être être là-bas mais voilà et
dans un dans un souci d'enquête
vous vous souvenez depuis combien de
jours elle a disparu la dame et ben
c'était au j'ai oublié
la disparu elle a pas disparu la pile
poils
aujourd'hui l'imprimerie non parce qu'on
se posait des questions au niveau de la
sécurité de ce cette jeune femme non
mais au pire
en fait on a fait l'appel et elle a
manqué à l'appel et on
l'a oui non mais la DHCP
on peut faire ça non on va juste à
l'entrée
pour savoir si c'est ce soir demain ou
après-demain
ces détails là on peut juste lui dire on
a trouvé cette note
on a entendu dire des collègues qui
parlaient de la forêt de
direct
comme ça elle voit la personne et pas
direct c'est réglé nous on se barre
Fredo il voudrait juste qu'on donne le
papier
je saurais David de laisser cette pauvre
dame tranquille mais voilà d'un côté on
donne un indice à Lara de l'autre on
laisse peut-être une chance à cette
pauvre dame une chance une chance
mais c'est pas la condamner encore plus
c'est juste fournir une information pour
que nous on puisse juste en lui disant
allez au sud de d'Iris dans la forêt
c'est l'information c'est bon
vous êtes trop vous voulez bien faire
bah oui perfectionniste
dans ces endroits si c'est votre site de
fou il y a mon avis c'est pas par hasard
vous voyez il y a pas des informations
dont vous étiez au courant par le passé
et si vous repreniez ce petit papier là
que vous allez mettre dans les archives
avant qu'on
transfuges
enfin j'arrive à avoir deux lettres mais
ça me fait je n'arrive pas à lire quoi
comme vous avez déchiffrer ce truc je
suis la seule à pas l'avoir déchiffrer
non mais vous êtes la seule à l'avoir
c'est
quoi moi je vois un
un H un P je sais pas ce que c'est je
vois il y a un mot là mais je sais pas
ce que c'est il y a sans doute oh est-ce
que je peux
tout un œil
comme ça
dis-moi
j'ai fait 42 comme de par hasard
c'est tout
double jeu
et attendez on peut pas appeler les
Aigles rouges aussi en même temps au
même endroit
[Musique]
je me casse
non non
non
moi je suis David
vraiment pas joli
il cherche telle personne qui sera
justement à tel endroit voilà
plus à la plus d'influence que moi bon
est-ce qu'on va pas juste se dans
la merde en fait donc toi Fredo tu dis
on retourne la voir et on lui dit bah on
a une info on tente d'abord ce truc
auprès d'elle on voit que moi elle
réagit oui peut-être elle nous dira non
c'est pas suffisant bon voilà peut-être
qu'on arrive à la convaincre que ça
suffit d'être utile est-ce qu'on a pas
besoin d'aide pour retourner d'avoir
besoin d'elle pas
avec le
[Musique]
colonel Beaulieu là où on lui
on lui dit parce qu'on a la formule du
truc et s'il a besoin on peut même faire
tourner l'usine parce que voilà on se
débrouille quoi non mais là vous voulez
monter un conflit joindre le colonel
Beaulieu
ou quelque chose
est-ce que je peux voir votre vieux
papier
[Musique]
on retourne voir là alors
on fait semblant de faire une enquête
quand même on revient
partout on fait on pose des questions
partout à tout le monde
se balade sur la place du marché on
parle aux gens
ils sont en train
d'enquêterez
de tout business de toute aller en avant
c'est la prise de risque
et cette gestion du risque c'est quelque
chose qu'en tant que président de CCI on
apprend très tôt
je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr de moi
bon vous faites quoi faut me dire un
truc parce que
pour moi on pose plein de questions aux
gens partout
Sherlock Holmes
tout le monde est au courant qu'on
cherche quelqu'un et on essaie de faire
vraiment on est avec Lara on bosse pour
elle quoi ça marche
et la dernière chose qu'on fait c'est on
va on dit qu'on va au truc
niveau là
ton site là de toute façon on va pas
pouvoir sortir mais si parce que si on
dit c'est pour on va avoir c'est bon
nous dire oui ou non
c'est un peu comme
si vous voyez dans l'entreprise c'est
d'aller au-delà
j'ai l'impression quoi c'est juste
problème solution là de la solution
c'est de faire de avancer les choses on
peut pas vendre la torche et avoir 213
du coup c'est ça moi
on y va ok oui
mais pour me donner du courage
j'ai ma petite torche magique
est-ce que quelqu'un nous arrête
personne nous arrête non d'accord donc
là on y va mais on y va vraiment on se
cache pas ouais vous y allez comment
vous vous éclairez parce que du coup
vous sortez un peu du village quand même
vous sortez des rues
une chacun bon on va pas allumer les
deux peut-être ok donc toi tu as une
batterie de 1 seulement
vous aviez deux batteries de deux donc
je suppose que vous voulez faire ça
mais
voilà et toi du coup tu t'en prends une
neuve dans ta torche de luxe ou tu
prends
celle de deux qui vont rester aussi
allez je prends c'est le de
mais s'il y a besoin
de batterie pour les gens derrière ok
vous savez pas je le dirai quand on
change les piles voilà
donc là pour l'instant ils ont une
batterie de 1 une batterie de 2
vous vous baladez avec votre torche
verte et votre torche bleu
magnifique et
Gloria tu arrives à un peu retrouver le
chemin de ce au bout d'un moment niveau
topographique tu dis ah oui c'est bon je
reconnais en fait mais c'est pas si loin
et donc vous arrivez dans une clairière
et vous trouvez c'est bien là
effectivement c'est bien là une entrée
de temple
puisque je retrouve c'est où que je l'ai
mis
[Musique]
tout à fait c'est un temple
excusez-moi madame
Proust voilà donc c'est une sorte de
grande infrastructure qui s'enfonce dans
le monde immeuble en fait
ça ça a été entièrement dédié comparé à
ton époque à toi donc là c'est vraiment
mise à jour entièrement un endroit
souterrain par contre il y a quelques
peintures sur les façades de l'entrée
des lunes noires
et un texte qui a marqué vous n'êtes pas
les bienvenus ici j'ai l'impression
bah ça s'est passé entre oui ça c'est
après notre disparition forcément parce
que nous on n'était pas ah non c'était
pas des Cavés quand excavé quand quand
j'étais donc je pouvais pas avoir à
l'intérieur
bon voilà
très bien
je veux aller voir ça non mais
malgré nos différents et votre obsession
des poteries
au-delà de tout sens économiques
j'ai quelques étagères à la maison
je m'engage à vous suivre dans cette
entre qui a l'air quand même un petit
peu dangereux mais voilà je les suis par
pur sympathie pour le clearson âgées
peut-être con mais allons-y ok donc en
gros
vous avez dans une espèce de Hall
centrale en fait avec des escaliers qui
continuent de descendre en avant et un
chemin sur la gauche et un chemin sur la
droite c'est très classique comme
construction finalement sur les murs il
y a pas mal de
d'instructions de d'illustrations gravée
d'époque donc toi tu es un peu fasciné
par ça parce que vous n'étiez pas encore
arrivé à ce niveau là de l'édifice par
contre ils sont extrêmement dégradés
notamment avec de la peinture noire et
des graffitis etc ça a été un peu
détruit en fait
c'est comme ça que faisait électricité
les aliens
[Musique]
tout ce savoir
que les pyramides c'est pour faire
l'électricité
je crois que
je crois que ça l'a pas fait mais en
tout cas c'est
les Mayas ont réussi par contre en
revanche
le choix c'est gauche droite non c'est
quoi gauche droite ou descendre en avant
une sorte de cantine il y a d'époque
template ou non ça a l'air récent un peu
fait à l'arrache mais en vrai du bon
matériel c'était pas là
il y a de la nourriture
donc on est
l'une noire
on est chez ceux qui vont qui vont buter
sur la pointe des pieds j'y vais et je
chope un blanc de dinde ok
j'imagine comme comme dans les films
d'Indiana Jones je prends la torche je
regarde
bah c'est en fait c'est dans un vieux
temple qui a été aménagé en cantine
je peux faire un jeu de fouille
de combat
pour faire des figurines avec du blanc
de dinde
oh
64 sur 45 donc je ne ferai pas de
figurer
oui un petit peu moi j'en prends j'en
donne un bouquin il est content c'est ça
qu'il avait senti un du coup c'est juste
la bouffe bon bah demi-tour
peut-être faisant un petit peu plus
attention on vous envoie un premier et
vous nous dites
entendu superbe
donc maintenant vous pouvez soit
descendre tout droit soit aller à droite
on la laisse quelques mètres en avant
moi je descends toute seule
vous restez là-haut tu prends une torche
je viens avec nous
la machette et on est prêt
vous descendez et à mesure que vous
descendez vous commencez entendre des
voix en fait
si j'éteins la torche au niveau encore
quelque chose rien du tout ça c'est le
monde il est comme ça
donc plus vous descendez plus les voix
se qu'on arrive à Disneyland
c'est pas clair ça parle pas forcément
dans une langue que vous reconnaissez et
ça limite l'air à mesure que vous vous
approchez d'être un rituel en fait il y
a quelqu'un qui dit des palabres et il y
a plein de gens qui répondent au coeur
ne serait-ce que le moindre particule de
lumière je suis David d'éteindre la
torche mais moi je pense qu'on peut
descendre dans le noir
non
c'est des petites marches
du coup vous allez me faire un agilité
tous les deux
vous descendez des escaliers vous
finissez pas entrer dans un dans un
globe de lumière effectivement qui est
assez large en fait selon toute la pièce
est éclairée en fait il y a plein de
personnes en cap avec des lunes dans le
dos qui sont tournés vers une espèce
d'estrade sur laquelle il y a une
personne avec une grande dose
qui est en train de faire des de faire
des de discuter enfin de dire des trucs
dans des langues dans une langue que
vous ne comprenez pas et il y a
quelqu'un d'allonger sur une table
devant lui et d'un coup le seul coup il
se met à crever un œil de la personne
allongé sur la table qui est toujours
consciente
qui ne se dépla pas spécialement
ici on remonte
je pense qu'on en a assez pour la on
fait descendre
je pense que avec ça Lara on a de quoi
l'occuper quoi oui
je peux faire un jeu un jet de courir
sauter
si vous tombez déjà j'ai failli vous
ramasser là non non tu peux courir dans
les escaliers
et vous remontez vous les retrouvez
et puis écoutez c'est pas la joie là de
toute façon
voilà donc là nous sommes des
randonneurs et nous sortons
alors moi je suis refroidis là
personnellement
de la cuisine c'est quoi que tu as du
blanc d'Inde mais justement
la lune quand c'est la dessiner et quand
je lui ai dit vous ça vous dit quelque
chose une lune elle a fait non aucune
idée on lui montre le dessin elle va y
aller
mais regardons vite fait dans le pièce
mais oui
jamais il y avait 600
dollars
mais si on trouve en plus d'argent oui
ça serait bien fou à donner voilà
nous reste dehors non vous y allez moi
j'y vais quand même
je viens aussi
[Musique]
et je vous suis
dans cet autre pièce vous tombez sur pas
mal de bureaux vous voyez des des
espèces de plants notamment un plan des
grottes les mêmes grottes que vous avez
parcouru lors du premier épisode qui
indique qu'il y a des schémas dans tous
les sens et il y a un espèce de brief de
il faut saboter le générateur ah bah oui
ça j'en savais que c'était
mais oui mais on avait eu
sur la cape
de la cape en fait
on va se barrer parce que la première
fois qu'on les a vu ils nous ont dit
est-ce que vous savez éviter les balles
en rigolant c'est ça autre chose que
vous voyez dans la salle c'est
des cages dans ce cas il y a deux femmes
elles
sont effrayés
écoutez je suis fan de votre travail
vraiment j'adore ce que vous faites
bougez pas j'ai un truc faut que j'aille
mais je reviens salut on va vous ouvrir
on va vous ouvrir
comment donc moi je regarde la cage tu
pourrais la forcer il y a pas
de quoi genre une barre de fer
j'ai un cruciforme
j'ai des agitateurs magnétiques
qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je fasse un G ou un petit jeu de
force vas-y
75 sur 75 bon si tu galères un peu mais
ça s'ouvre
ouf ça fait un bon
bruit qui résonne bien vous ouvrez la
cage
et l'autre
les chiens ils fonctionnent pas comme
nous non c'est juste pour les
tremblements de terre ça marche pas pour
les autres pardon peut-être que dans ce
monde
je m'approche de l'autre cage et je
demande à la dame comment il s'appelle
les deux étoiles
bon bah venez avec nous on se casse
plutôt prestement je suppose on y
retourner vers iridis alors attends
parce que là il faut qu'on discute sur
le trajet
on a récupéré Mélissa
elle voulait Mélissa en 2016 qu'on lui
donne alors là on parle sans que Mélissa
nous entende oui oui peut-être un peu
lui demander
qu'est-ce qui vous arrive et on le pour
pouvoir l'aider bah ma fille du coup
c'est l'autre personne que vous avez
libéré elle a été capturée par par eux
là je sais pas qui c'est et ils m'ont
demandé une rançon j'ai amené la rançon
et ils m'ont pris la rançon et moi avec
un du coup
ça vous arrive souvent ce genre de
d'aventure
sur 10 comment est-ce que
vous avez vous avez zéro
vous avez pas récupéré l'argent
vous vous doutez bien que non
[Musique]
je pense pas non elle a quel âge la
fille
merci je pense si on amène cette dame à
la
bon Lara elle sera un peu énervée parce
que la pulat d'une et peut-être qu'elle
lui proposera de travailler pour elle
voilà
non mais oui c'est pas là je pense que
c'est
vous avez vu ce qu'elle a fait à Dr
Nigel mais justement là on le ramène
romain d'olive
justement ce que je disais c'est plus
donc là moi je pense qu'on ramène
Mélissa là-bas et on essaie de dire de
négocier
il faut peut-être s'en inquiéter quoi ok
donc on vous retournez à Éric vous vous
dirigez vers
chez Lara et en fait sur le chemin vous
faites une rencontre un peu bizarre
il y a quelqu'un qui vous croise qui a
de très beaux vêtements une petite
boucle d'oreille avec un sablier qui
vous regarde avec un grand sourire qui
est un très chaleureux qui vous dit
c'est vous qui venez du passé
bonjour ah bah ça fait plaisir notre
connu comme ça au moment où vous dites
ça ou vous confirmez du coup ce qu'il
dit il sort un appareil photo
il s'en va
quelle personne sympathique mais du coup
on le suit
on lui dit bonjour attendez
moi j'ai une barre
justice
par le bras il se retourne vers toi son
visage il est effrayant il te dit
lâche-moi
tu as peur
vraiment il était frais et bouga il a
peur oui
en pleine rue
vous êtes dans le village il y a des
gens
là que vous avez pris il te prend la
main il te la brouint un peu pour te
faire lâcher et ça te fait vraiment mal
[Musique]
mais qui êtes-vous on est les gens du
passé
de
la barre de fer dans le menu
quête et nickel quoi je prends la barre
de fer
je vis et il est dodo du coup
sans problème
je suis beau je continue son chemin
ouais je fais ce que tu dis je sors ma
torche magique et j'essaye de le de le
un peu
quand tu continues à t'avancer il
appelle la police
il appelle la police
on se calme excusez-nous monsieur
excusez-nous il s'en va je vous invite
cordialement à partir
de quoi et des photos donc vous vous
rendez chez Lara avec Mélissa du coup je
suppose oui ok et sa fille
[Musique]
prendre des risques elle saura lui
trouver donnez moins de coup demain
elle va garder sa fille et la faire
souffrir comme les autres
je suis pas personnellement investi dans
la vie de tous ces gens là
vous voulez négocier avec Mélissa alors
que ça se trouve elle va nous elle va
nous faire comme Romain doline on va
finir la tête au carré
moi ma théorie
mon idée c'est on prend Mélissa on
l'amène à Lara Lara vous les Mélissa
point barre mais je suis totalement
d'accord elle saura être raisonnable
mais oui
de toute façon elle lui doit si ça se
dit roi elle va pas la tuer ça va
l'amener à quoi il lui manquera toujours
600 0 donc en tant que puissant en tant
que président de CCI
il faut toujours flatter les puissants
et là c'est ce qu'on va faire
allons-y allez ok vous rentrez dans le
bureau donc avec la fille aussi non non
sans la fille tout le monde tout le
monde le chien est-ce que vous la
laissez partir
est-ce que je peux rester avec la fille
dehors et puis ensuite elle doit dire
des trucs là enfin je veux dire on
l'amène en face de la fin c'est très
bien que lui doit elle est comment la
Mélissa quand vous arrivez devant chez
Lara oui et Mélissa qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit elle vous dit s'il vous plaît ma
fille a rien à voir là-dedans ok mais
moi d'accord c'est pas un problème
jusqu'au feu de joie et on garde les
couleurs
OK
tu vas sur la plage du coup toi c'est un
jeu d'intelligence oh la vache
ça va toujours réussir ça
70 sur 35 ça c'est pas bon sur 35 tu as
très envie d'acheter quelque chose dans
ce marché
Lara elle se redresse elle dit et ben
vous voyez que 48 heures c'était
largement voilà donc maintenant on va
ressortir notre dette est effacée et
merci tiens de tes paroles si vous
voulez travailler avec moi ou louer de
mes services n'hésitez pas vous êtes
désormais les amis de Lara
je vais régler cette histoire avec
Mélissa
et bien bonne soirée
de pas abîmer
comme je l'ai dit elle lui doit de
l'argent ils vont s'arranger elle va pas
froidement comme vous voulez qu'est-ce
que tu veux acheter toi
permettrait de lire Fergie de la Robin
sonne
non je ne sais pas qu'est-ce que je
pourrais acheter
une bague
une bague ça va coûter cher c'est
bêtises
en 2200
[Musique]
j'achète un sarouel j'ai toujours voulu
un
sarouels
[Musique]
je vous le prends pour trois
miroirs de la nouvelle monnaie du coup
ce que je fais de plus marchandeuse que
et bah très bien pour 5 je vous prends
donc un magnifique sarouel
[Musique]
la main sur le truc non plus quoi enfin
pour être compliqué
[Musique]
ils ont trouvé Mélissa ils se sont
barrés directs ils l'ont laissé sur
place non non ils l'ont récupéré mais
ils ont séquestré dans leur chambre
d'hôtel et ils sont allés voir Lara en
disant que Mélissa tu es toujours dans
le truc de la secte en disant il y a des
gens dangereux va falloir y aller armer
ils ont prévu l'armée en disant il y
aura les gens de Lara et ils seront
affaiblis parce qu'ils vont se battre
contre d'autres gens et ils se sont
barrés d'iridis c'est juste déclencher
une guerre
je pense que c'est la guerre totale et
un autre avantage là mais
là quand vous avez dit on va prévenir
les Aigles rouges et tout je te vois là
dedans non
mais vous en êtes bien sorti
[Musique]
ah non mais moi c'est que c'est qu'il
est églantine a beaucoup de points de
vie encore je pense que il y a deux
trois derrière
le truc c'est que elle fait des trucs
bizarres mais jamais agressif du coup
je pense que après ce test il suffit
d'aller il y a pas loin à aller pour
tester voir ce que ça
en face d'une personne armée lourdement
voir ce que ça donne mais après possible
hein
tu me diras pour l'épisode suivant
voilà
[Rires]
[Musique]
très envie de le faire maintenant du
coup
je vais me prendre le chat donc si vous
avez des questions
attendez attendez les mettez pas tout de
suite parce que je sais pas pourquoi
mais après j'ai pas l'historique du chat
c'est bon à partir de maintenant vous
pouvez poser des questions je vais les
voir n'hésitez pas alors
la monnaie tout de suite la monnaie
est-ce que c'était
un peu mieux
il y avait des trucs
c'est pas hallucinant dans un marché
d'avoir
plusieurs prix en différentes ouais
surtout si c'est le marché qui est la
plaque tournante du commerce de la
région est-ce qu'il y aurait une monnaie
pour autant enfin je sais pas combien de
personnes qui vivent dans les villages
tu vois mais on peut penser que vu qu'il
communique souvent moi je me suis
imaginé ça je me suis imaginé horizon
qui les Aigles rouges qui veulent mettre
leur loi et qui font le dollar d'horizon
donc ils reprennent l'ancienne monnaie
mais à leur sauce et les petits villages
qui se sentent un peu
un peu forcés là-dessus et qui veulent
garder plutôt leur indépendance et leur
souveraineté qui du coup en seule
réponse il crée leur propre monnaie je
me suis dit comme ça je sais pas si
c'est ridicule ou pas
pourquoi pas après c'est juste que du
coup ça veut dire que dans les petits
villages il y aurait un mécanisme
c'est juste qui est entre le maire et
[Musique]
quel est l'organisme qui gère cette
monnaie là tu vois ça pourrait être Lara
comme ça pourra être
dit c'est une banque vous auriez pu y
aller pour faire des échanges de monnaie
qui ont été peut-être un peu plus à vos
autres avantages
ah bah voilà là on a préféré
[Musique]
ok d'accord
et donc le temple sélénique c'est un
vrai truc ça les trucs c'est limite ou
pas
[Musique]
c'était une croyance qu'autre chose
dans la Grèce antique si tu dis pas de
bêtises mais c'est complètement faux
mais c'était quand il croyaient à leur
époque qu'il y avait des hommes sur la
Lune et en fait le peuple de la lune
c'était les séléni c'est pas vraiment
faux ça
le sacrifice là qui est à la fin
ce type de rituel ça a existait en fait
ça a été fils humain ça les Mayas n'en
parlons pas mais même
le culte de mitrate par exemple c'est
c'est sacrifices enfin oui qu'est-ce que
c'est le culte de Mithra le tilde
s'inculte un peu
comment dire
c'est un culte qui vient de Lorient il y
a pas mal de culte orientaux qui
arrivent qui sont vachement acceptés par
des populations à Rome enfin dans les
villes de Méditerranée occidentale
et en fait ça ça consiste à
mettre des humains en cage c'est à dire
qu'on fait un trou dans le sol on met
une grille de métal enfin vraiment c'est
un animal Lecter et dessus on met un
souvent un bœuf qu'on égorge et en fait
les les croyants essaient de recevoir un
maximum de 100 de cet animal sur eux
un samedi soir comme un autre
complètement
là j'ai pu je crois que c'est quand même
antiquité tardive pour moi c'est un truc
qui arrive je pense troisième quatrième
siècle de notre ère un truc assez et
est-ce qu'il y a des particularités
qui font comme ça des sacrifices enfin
de manière plus large est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui est qualifié comme
sacrifice humain est-ce que par exemple
tous les trucs de l'Inquisition ou des
choses comme ça où c'était plus des
accusations de trucs de sorcière ou de
sacrifices
pour chasser parce que tu es impie enfin
c'est-à-dire que tu as un problème voilà
tu es puni c'est
mais il y a pas de rapprochement enfin
dans les études un peu de société
qui sont faites sur les Mayas ce qu'on
comprend c'est que c'est un honneur en
fait d'être sacrifié tu as toujours ce
truc de ah c'est forcément des ennemis
vaincus et donc on se sert d'eux comme
chez humaine quoi comme
en fait on se rend compte qu'il y a des
enfants qui a tellement de pour les
Mayas enfin en tout cas ce qui se
passait à théoti-wan à côté de Mexico il
y a tellement de sang il y a tellement
tellement de sang
que il y a beaucoup de gens et que c'est
des gens de la population en fait et tu
as ça aussi en Grèce voilà
tu l'as dans la mythologie mais en fait
la mythologie elle prend des choses qui
sont dans les dans le
une part de réel en fait
comment
du sang et tout enfin les manuscrits tu
as des archives en fait
comme les crues
je pense qu'elle est encore en ligne
mais c'était genre en janvier sur France
Culture il y avait une émission
là-dessus et ils avaient des voilà il y
avait des exemples très concrets de
combien il y avait d'humains en telle
période de temps quel âge des femmes des
enfants des jeunes
et comment tu tu sais que c'est des
sacrifices c'est pas juste un cimetière
parce que c'est lié à
déjà un édifice on est un temple prête à
des bas reliefs qui te représentent ça
c'est l'histoire tu vois
qui te disent ça ensuite c'est pas une
histoire qui est c'est pas très vieux en
fait
tout ça c'est notre Moyen-Âge à nous
donc en fait des sources textuelles on
en a quoi tu vois oui c'est vrai parce
que ça se passait en même temps
1000 mais les derniers parce que la
conquista
quoi donc eux ils sont arrivés ils ont
pu voir
et est-ce qu'on a une idée de
quels sont les parties enfin qu'est-ce
que ça rapporte à une culture parce que
j'imagine qu'il y a un avantage d'une
certaine manière à faire ça c'est
une des hypothèses qui est le plus
avancée c'est
mais c'était culturel c'est-à-dire que
ça rééquilibre
des forces c'est à dire que
il faut baisser de toute façon tous les
sacrifices mais même les sacrifices on a
toujours sacrifié des animaux pour les
dieux pour les dieux c'est le sang les
organes c'est de la nourriture pour les
dieux et les humains ils récupèrent les
mauvais morceaux les banquiers
funéraires en Grèce c'est ça c'est les
meilleurs parties odieux
tu les laisses sur des coupelles quoi tu
es toi tu manges les parties
mais pour les humains et pour les
humains c'est pareil quoi c'est c'est
les entrailles c'est de la c'est de la
nourriture à Dieu et donc c'est à
superstition en fait c'est vraiment pour
s'assurer on a fait le max pour se
mettre les dieux de son côté quoi mais
il y avait pas de
d'espèces davantage enfin
[Musique]
dans le genre
une espèce de contrôle de la population
ou de trucs
mais
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment il y a pas
de raison démographique c'est
de la culture quoi on est enfin c'est
une manière de se représenter le monde
voilà c'est
il y a ça dans plusieurs civilisations
qui n'ont rien à voir les unes avec les
autres du coup c'est marrant
c'est exactement le mot que je cherchais
trop drôle
et est-ce qu'on a des cultures qui sont
passées de fin genre en Grèce est-ce que
c'était avant les espèces de trucs enfin
la question que j'essaie de poser c'est
est-ce que on peut imaginer un peu notre
société qui revient à des trucs de
sacrifices comme ça où comment est-ce
qu'il
est-ce que c'est nous ce qu'on peut
quand est-ce qu'on a trouvé sa barbare
quoi enfin c'est ça ta question ou c'est
plus est-ce que c'était contemporain de
des trucs philosophiques un peu à la
Platon et tout ça ou est-ce que c'était
pas du tout ce moment-là ou c'est en
fait c'est pas de la philosophie parce
qu'en plus les philosophes Socrates lui
il se moque de ça il dit mais c'est
débile aucun cadeau ne peut satisfaire
les dieux les dieux s'en fichent sont
au-dessus de ça et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'il se fait condamner enfin tu vois
c'est c'est vraiment ce ce c'est une
c'est une croyance et on n'est pas
c'est des civilisation il y a pas de
technologie la science ne répond pas aux
questions de vie de mort de naissance
ça
marche il y a des petites questions mais
c'est plus dans l'ordre du scénario je
pense il y a l'usine était un moyen pour
eux de récupérer de l'argent oui
si vous aviez voulu juste travailler à
l'usine pendant 5 heures vous en serez
fait un peu d'argent de poche en plus ça
c'était complètement mais ça ça implique
de croire à la valeur travail
pour nous encore
est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé d'une
manière ou d'une autre que enfin des
métiers comme ça au juste tu peux
arriver pointer alors que tu n'as pas de
dire j'arrive je travaille 3 heures pour
vous vous me payez je m'en vais
encore aujourd'hui
très loin le travail à la tâche et à
l'heure et tout ça déjà c'est
je dirais pas que c'est la majeure
partie du monde qui travaille comme ça
mais tu as beaucoup de pays où l'âme une
grosse partie du travail c'est du
travail un peu gris un petit peu parce
que c'est pas complètement illégal mais
en même temps c'est pas vraiment déclaré
enfin il y a une parole déclarée quoi
donc tu c'est juste tu arrives tu bosses
et tu repars quoi et ça ça
donc déjà au 19e siècle en France
c'était classique quoi c'est genre tu
bosses pour la journée
et puis le lendemain tu sais faire là je
veux pas non plus enfin je suis pas sûr
de ça mais tu avais pas mal de
enfin tant que dès que tu as pas de
droit du travail forcément l'avantage
c'est de dire voilà t'attendre devant
l'usine on te prend et tu fais ta
journée et puis tu ressors du truc
usine ou autre chose et encore
aujourd'hui il suffit d'aller je sais
pas dans Paris devant beaucoup de
magasins de de bricolage de trucs enfin
il y a des spots comme ça où tu as des
personnes qui attendent toute la journée
pour où c'est il travaille une heure
deux heures enfin et c'est juste le
travail sans code du travail sans droit
sans loi sans rien du tout c'est il
s'organise un peu comme ça quoi c'est si
tu viens tu fais tes 3 heures tu es payé
si tout va bien parce que après
forcément ça ouvre plein de d'abus de
partout quoi parce que c'est du en bas
non je t'ai pas vu bosser bon allez je
te paye pas enfin voilà
et après c'est toute la
enfin en France justement il y a eu pas
mal de de
régulation de ça d'éviter de faire que
les gens puissent travailler à la table
enfin d'être payé à la tâche je crois
que c'est ça ça arrive encore mais je
sais pas trop parce que j'étais dans
certaines usines il y a des gens qui
travaillent à la tâche mais en même
temps c'est pas vraiment enfin je sais
pas je regarde c'est une bonne question
ouais bon termites
dans l'auto-entreprise aujourd'hui pose
des questions en régie ça parle de uber
bah justement l'ubérisation ça remet pas
mal ça en question et on revoit les
travers du truc qui arrive avec des gens
qui en fait sont factuellement payés à
la tâche les chauffeurs ubers sont payés
à la table mais c'est parce qu'il y a
une grosse entreprise qui
[Musique]
qui utilise le statut là non mais en
vrai même les pigistes pour moi ils sont
payés à la tâche en fait
c'est pour dire mais justement le truc
de pigiste c'est censé les protéger
d'une certaine manière et d'une certaine
manière ça le fait après c'est juste que
tu as un ou les paquets une offre mais
c'est pareil c'est tout ça c'est des
contrats qui sont un petit peu on
s'arrange un petit peu pour offrir de la
flexibilité à des entreprises ou à des
services publics qui en cherchent
beaucoup et ont des espèces de petits
passes droits sur des trucs
mais justement l'auto-entreprise ça pose
des grosses questions à ce niveau là de
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
recréer ce
petit marché brocante du job du job qui
est tu bosses 2h parce que là ce qu'on
voit dans les créations de de
micro-entreprise c'est que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont loin du SMIC
loin du SMIC et qui sont
un petit peu piégés dans ces systèmes là
quoi enfin c'est dur d'en sortir donc ça
pose des vraies questions sur le ouais
c'est enfin encore une fois la valeur
travail quoi c'est
on en revient on en revient toujours
toujours là quoi c'est bien beau de le
dire c'est autre chose de le faire que
le travail et de la valeur et comment tu
comment tu partages cette valeur comment
tu t'organiser cette valeur comment tu
fais que les
que la classe de travailleurs puisse
être protégée et existe et
voilà ça c'est toute une organisation à
avoir
OK et j'en ai une autre c'est qu'est-ce
qui fait que l'ancienne monnaie a
toujours de la valeur alors ça moi je me
suis imaginé
faut juste faire le petit travail que je
me suis fait mentalement en gros on est
dans un monde qui s'est effondré des
sociétés de la société qui s'est isolées
parce que du coup ils ne peuvent plus
trop communiquer des uns avec les autres
et on se retrouve du coup avec une
ancienne monnaie qui est finie soit
c'est à dire que il y a une quantité
mais il n'est plus créée c'était plus du
tout la priorité vitale au début donc
certes elle peut circuler pour le début
je suppose je me tu m'arrête à Arnaud si
je dis des conneries il va circuler mais
si la population recommence à grandir
les besoins vont être de plus en plus
grands et s'il y a toujours le même
nombre de monnaies du coup elle va finir
par exploser en termes de valeur
du coup il vaut peut-être mieux passer à
une monnaie sur laquelle on peut
remettre la main pour essayer de un peu
plus manipuler sa valeur je sais pas
après je pense que ça
comment on en parlait l'autre fois tu as
tellement de dangereux de puissance sur
la monnaie ouais que en vrai il y a
assez peu de chance que la l'ancienne
monnaie encore de la valeur parce que tu
vas avoir soit horizons les Aigles
rouges là ou soit le maire ou avec Lara
ou d'autres personnes
qui vont prendre le compte enfin qui
vont créer leur monnaie et qui vont dire
non mais
il y a pas de il y a pas d'échange quoi
enfin tu vois aucune aucun intérêt
là-dedans en fait tu vois ouais mais
est-ce que socialement du coup ça le
ferait que ces organisations disent bah
tu toi tu étais riche tu reviens à zéro
toi tu étais pauvre tu reviens à zéro
aussi et on recommence tous à zéro
ça ne se passe jamais vraiment comme ça
parce que les les gens qui sont riches
dans une société généralement ils ont
aussi autre chose
sociale ils ont tu vois si tu produisais
je sais pas si tu avais une usine ou si
tu avais une position rien qu'une
position sociale
en fait tu l'as toujours quoi donc
l'argent c'est juste des chiffres et en
fait tu vois même si l'argent enfin
ça peut être compliqué mais
c'est qu'une mesure sociale d'une
certaine mesure aussi et donc tu peux
retrouver cette position et tu as plein
de gens qui en fait ça va être du genre
il serait pas inquiet sur le changement
parce qu'il se dirait juste bah oui
d'accord Lara on est super pote j'étais
riche avant je vais être riche
maintenant ok sinon tu es contre moi et
du coup tu te fais c'est juste aussi un
truc politique quoi donc je pense qu'il
y a pas de problème à ce que il y a eu
une autre monnaie qui arrive d'un coup
en mode
tu as la tête du maire ou je sais pas
qui et puis c'est dans l'ancienne elle a
plus aucune valeur moi juste collection
quoi mais ce serait c'est assez
difficile d'imaginer pourquoi il aurait
de la valeur enfin
vu l'intérêt qu'il y a de contrôler la
monnaie même dans des sociétés enfin
ça parait assez difficile quand même
elle pourrait pas servir de justement
d'intermédiaire entre mes deux monnaies
de ville
parce qu'il y a aussi ça en fait c'est
un peu compliqué parce que là on est
dans un espèce de petit micro Cosme et
en fait il y a un autre village qui
rentre en contact avec eux qui arrivent
et qui disent bah nous on a gardé
[Musique]
si je te livre enfin c'est est-ce que du
coup c'est pas bien d'avoir si on prend
par du principe on est dans un pays où
tout le monde a la même monnaie paf on
partit maintenant tout en petit village
qui vont tous leur monnaie mais du coup
ils se réfère tout ça l'ancienne pour
avoir leur valeur de monnaie
individuelle elle a pas vraiment de
enfin elle a pu elle a plus aucune
valeur à partir du moment
si tu veux c'est juste si tu as pas le
truc ou la justice
enfin désolé on parle beaucoup de
monnaie mais c'est juste une c'est
intéressant si tu as pas le
truc en fait c'est
la
si tu veux régler une dette dans
n'importe quoi en peau de Babybel ou un
truc comme ça tu peux le faire tu vois
tant que les deux personnes sont ok ils
disent ok
je te vends
quatre ordinateurs pour 25 chaises mais
quand tu veux tu fais ça quand tu veux
si tu fais 25 ordinateurs contre 45
roubles tu le fais aussi tu fais ce que
tu veux par contre au bout d'un moment
en dernier recours tu vois là tu vas
voir la justice et tu vas avoir un peu
le truc de force légitime qui vont dire
non bah là en fait
il faut de l'euro on reconnaît que de
l'euro et c'est là en fait que tu as la
valeur vraiment de du truc c'est que
c'est pas juste tu as la signature mais
tu as aussi un peu le bâton derrière tu
vois
c'est ça c'est si un moment
la dernière monnaie tu vois c'est
le contraire c'est le contrat social qui
est avec derrière même si c'est pas la
banque la banque européenne qui est une
police tu vois mais
il y a une police qui est quelque part
et qui va te dire ce qui va te dire non
bah là maintenant on paye en euros voilà
et donc là je pense qu'il y aurait pas
ce sans avoir ce truc là ça va plus être
je pense la personne qui contrôle la
force donc Lara ou le maire tu sais qui
pourrait avoir deux
presque monnaie un peu parallèle ou
juste un système de dette tu vois de qui
est pas qui est pas avec des billets tu
vois mais juste ils ont des systèmes un
peu parallèles et c'est celui qui
contrôle la force qui contrôle le enfin
c'est vraiment ça quoi c'est quand on
parle de toutes les débats là en ce
moment sur la
force légitimée et tout c'est parce que
à la base tout ce contrat social il est
qui peut forcer quelqu'un à faire
quelque chose quoi
voilà et puis l'argent c'est juste un
espèce de lubrifiant social de comment
ça comment tu changes
donc voilà ok très intéressant du coup
bon dans le cadre du jeu votre argent
elle aura de la valeur parce que
je viens que vous puissiez acheter des
trucs
on peut imaginer par contre que
quelqu'un a décidé de garder la vieille
monnaie et protège cette vieille monnaie
pour une raison pour une autre c'est
peut-être les Aigles rouges ils sont en
mode bah non on garde l'ancienne monnaie
comme ça et puis c'est tout on est dans
ma tête c'était les Aigles rouges ils
veulent la garder mais du coup ils sont
obligés de la reprendre un peu à leurs
sauces
ça ça peut ça peut marcher mais c'est
juste que du coup tu as une un truc
centralisé qui dit ça c'est l'argent que
je reconnais OK
sinon je pense c'est difficile
bon moi j'ai pas d'autres questions dans
le chat donc si vous en avez la balance
est maintenant je pense qu'on va
s'arrêter parce que moi j'ai pas
d'autres idées de quoi revenir j'ai
déchiffré ceci c'est bon je le garde
pour la prochaine émission comme tu veux
c'est pas vrai je peux dire maintenant
c'est toi qui vois
et j'ai fini par lire love moi j'ai
juste love
je pense que c'est écrit temple de la
lune
en dessous de l'une dans ce sens sombre
depuis le début
les notes
je crois qu'en fait tu es la première
mission tu l'as dit mais tu as pas fait
gaffe non non
je parle pas de l'émission de test
je parle sur youtube il y a quelqu'un
qui a mis un commentaire sur la première
VOD
pas du test non plus oui j'ai vu sur la
VOD j'ai vu aussi dans le chat twitch
c'est toi tu as pas regardé
en fait
du coup il y a rien eu de géologique
a pas une couche de sang dans le sol non
non non
c'est pas cool tu peux pas avoir du
liquide en plus
je fais une lune noire sur mon carnet si
ça pourrait marcher s'il y avait genre
une couche ultra imperméable genre je
sais pas une cuve de béton et comme par
hasard il y a 1000 sacrifices par dessus
et ensuite une autre couche de béton
ouais c'est ça et
quelle est la stabilité de l'hémoglobine
dans le temps je sais pas quoi enfin on
dirait un problème de maths de CE2
dalle de béton merde des mots globines
bon bah allez on va s'arrêter là c'est
déjà un bon moment là on a un peu duré
plus que que prévu très bien mais
c'était quand même très très cool
passez une bonne soirée derrière votre
écran merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve
dans deux semaines pour l'épisode 4
bisous
[Musique]